[music]
y'all excited for. I'm glad you guys are
here. Uh we are now in our final debate
of the evening. Um, this is one of our
main finales, our grand finale, should I
say. One of our better debates. Uh, not
better debates, but one of our
anticipated debates, should I say. And
so, I'm glad you guys stuck around. As
you guys see, I have Mr. Avery Austin,
God Logic.
He's here.
I have Jake Britella. Did I say that
right? Did I say it right? I said it
right. All right. All right. also known
as a Muslim metaphysician. And so we are
going to have a fun one today or this
evening in this debate. And so let me uh
introduce the debaters. And so we can
get this show on the road.
All right. Starting with Avery. Avery is
the founder of a Christian YouTube
channel, God Logic Apologetics, launched
in 2022. Avery is a Christian apologist
who regularly hosts open discussions and
debates with Muslims, Hebrew Israelites,
Jehovah's Witnesses, and others with a
focus on biblical clarity and respectful
dialogue. Please welcome Avery Austin.
All right. Jake Breant Brankantella uh
also known as Muslim metaphysician is a
Muslim apologist who holds a master's
degree in theology and philosophy. uh
his research focused on Islamic
theology, Christian theology, and early
Christian history. He currently resides
in Morocco with his family. Let's
welcome Jake.
All right, the topic of this debate is
does Islam teach the entire Bible? Uh it
teach the entire Bible is true, also
known as the Islamic dilemma. Uh this
debate format for this will be 18-minute
opening statements. It' be eight minute
rebuttals, a 40-minute cross examination
where both parties will get 20 minutes
each to ask questions. Then we uh go to
a five-minute closings and then 30-minut
Q&A from the audience. Sounds good.
All right. All right. Uh Avery, you're
arguing affirmative this debate. So,
you'll be up first for your opening
statement.
Testing, testing, testing.
Can you guys hear me? We all good?
What's going on, y'all?
Man, good to be here. Good to be here.
Thank you so much, Marlin, for having me
for this discussion, for this debate.
Thank you, Jake, for showing up unlike
some others.
And he knows what I'm talking about,
too, man. Jake a real one. I got to let
y'all know that. Um, does the Quran,
does Islam affirm the Bible in its
entirety? And the answer is a resounding
heck yeah. Duh. Have you guys ever read
the Quran before? I have. I've read a
couple times. Almost said my shahada,
too. Um, but luckily, I left Islam as
soon as I was born. Um, because we're
all born Muslims, according I guess. Um,
but we're going to talk about the
Islamic dilemma. When I saw the Islamic
dilemma, ladies and gentlemen, I was
like, "Dang, this is solid. There is no
way I can even return to Islam after
knowing this, you know." And so when we
get into this, this has been such a
plague within the Islamic community
among the Da guys, the Da Bros to the
point where we get a bunch of different
uh responses and reactions to the
Islamic dilemma. Matter of fact, there's
a lot of infighting with these guys
because they don't like how one is
responding to the argument. They think
that their response is better and the
other person think that their response
is better and then we just get the da
drama and we can watch it all on one way
apologetic. Shout out to you Chris
Claus. So, with that being said, we're
going to talk about what the Islamic
dilemma is.
And then we're going to also talk about
what the Islamic dilemma is not because
listening to Jake over the past few
days, it seems that my friend does not
know what in the world the Islamic
dilemma is. And this would be a tough
debate, bro, if you don't know what it
is, man. But it's okay. I'm here for
you, man. I'm I'm on your side. So, this
is what the Islamic dilemma is, guys.
The Islamic dilemma is this. It's the
concept that the Quran affirms the
Bible, the preservation of the Bible,
the inspiration of the Bible, and the
authority of the Bible. It affirms the
inspiration, the preservation, and the
authority of our scriptures. This is
what the Quran talks about. Now, here's
the problem. Unfortunately for the
Quran, the Quran tends to contradict
what the Bible says. It denies the deity
of Christ. It denies the crucifixion. It
denies the sunship of of Jesus. It
denies the trinity. So there are things
that the Quran directly contradicts. And
this is the problem. The fact that the
Quran says that our scriptures are true
while at the same time contradicting our
scriptures means that the Quran is
false. Oh, but there's a solution,
right? It's been corrupted. It's been
changed. Paul went to the council of
Nika, traveled in time and corrupted the
scriptures at the council of Nika. You
guys heard this before. Yeah, I've seen
y'all, you know, nodding your heads. We
all heard this before, right? So, it's
been tampered with. It's been corrupted.
There it is. Oh, but this is the other
side of the dilemma. It's because, okay,
if we're going to say that these
scriptures are corrupted, then the Quran
is false because it's affirming false
books. It's saying that corrupted,
changed books are true. So either way
you go, you're in trouble. It's a
dilemma. That's what the Islamic dilemma
is. Okay. Now, for you guys, I know we
got some Christians in here. What's the
only thing we do around here, y'all?
>> We just read. Is that right? So, we're
just going to go ahead and get a few
verses in here. In chapter 2, verse 41
of the Quran, it says, "And believe in
that I have sent down." Believe in what
I have sent down, confirming that which
is with you. and be not the first to
disbelieve in it and sell not my signs
for a little price and fear you me. So
the Quran here is telling the Jews to
believe in the Quran that which I have
revealed confirming that which is
already with you. So the scriptures that
the that the Jews have, the Torah, the
Psalms, these scriptures are true
according to the Quran. And the Quran is
in line with it, which is why the Jews
should believe in the Quran, too,
because they're all on the same side
according to the Quran. But according to
our dawa bros, we're going to hear
something else. We're team Allah today.
I know. I can't believe I'm saying this.
We're team Allah today. We're going to
defend Allah. Chapter 2, verse 85. I
love this verse. Jake loves it, too.
Then there are there you are killing one
another and expelling a party of you
from their habitations,
conspiring against them in sin and
immity. And if they come to you as
captives, you ransom them. Yet their
expulsion was forbidden you. Now this is
the special part. Watch this y'all. It
says, "What do you believe in part of
the book while rejecting the rest?"
Uh-oh. Wait. Our Muslim friends would
tell us that. No. No. No, no, no. Uh,
the the Quran is confirming part of your
scripture, some of your scripture. Allah
says, uh, uh-uh. He says, "Do you
believe in part of the book while
rejecting the rest?" What happens to
those who do that? Allah, he going to
tell us real quick. He says, "What
happens to those who do so among you
except degra deg degradation in this
life, disgrace in this life, and in the
hereafter there awaits for them the most
the the most uh uh heinous torment,
hell, y'all in in short terms. You're
going to go to hell if you believe in
part of the scripture and reject other
parts of the scripture." So according to
the Quran, we have an explicit verse, a
clear verse, an unambiguous statement
from the Quran itself that you cannot
believe in part of the book and reject
other parts of the book. But guess what
you're going to see today? You're going
to see that my opponent here is going to
actually advocate for believing and
affirming part of the scripture and
rejecting other parts. So my challenge
to Jake here today is to give me one
unequivocal statement, one unambiguous
verse where the Quran itself says you
can believe in some parts and reject
other parts. That's what I want to see
because I gave you explicitly what I am
saying from the Quran because we just
read. I want you to show me what you're
going to be saying from the Quran. Let's
keep going. Chapter 2 vers 89. It's
going to be a lot of chapter 2, y'all.
It says, "When there came to them a book
from God confirming what was with them."
Well, uh-oh. The Quran is confirming
what is with them. Again, what they have
possession of the Torah. And they and
they a four times prayed for victory
over the unbelievers. When there came to
them when there came to them that they
recognized, they disbelieved in it. And
the curse of God is is on the
unbelievers. Now, here's a question. How
in the world are they going to recognize
the Quran or the coming of Muhammad if
they don't have the scriptures to
recognize him with? That doesn't make
any sense to me. So, it looks like the
Quran is being very clear, standing 10
toes on the truth, the inspiration, and
the preservation of the previous
scriptures. As a matter of fact, it's
they're they're so true that this is the
reason why the Jews and Christians
should be believing in the Quran because
the Quran is is a a fulfillment of what
they have. The Quran is in line with
what they have. So the fact that they
see Muhammad, they see the Quran and
reject it means that they are turning
away from something they recognize.
So there's no way there's no excuse for
the people of the book. There's no
excuse. We should be believing in
Muhammad as a prophet and the Quran as a
revelation from Allah. Let's keep going.
Chapter 2 verse 91. Just two verses
later. And when they were told, believe
in what God has sent down, they said,
"We believe in what was sent down to
us." And they disbelieve in what is
beyond that. Yet it is the truth
confirming what is with them. say, "Why
then were you slaying the prophets of
God in former time if you were
believers?" Again, we're going to
continue to see this trend that the
Quran is confirming what is with them,
confirming what they have, confirming
what you possess. But what he's going to
say is they didn't have it. What he's
going to say is believe in part of it.
What he's going to say is, "Oh, it's
corrupted." What team are we on, Jake?
Or we going to be on team Allah today?
Y'all let me know. I I'mma choose I'mma
choose team Allah today. Chapter 3:3 of
the Quran. Next chapter, he has sent
down upon thee the book with truth,
confirming what was before it. And he
sent down the Torah and the Gospel.
There it is again. So, we see explicitly
what the Quran is confirming. Chapter
3:81. I love this. Let me actually save
that one for later. Here's 4:47. It
says, "You who have been given the
book," that's you guys, the Jews and
Christians, "You guys who have been
given the book, believe in what we have
sent down." Why? Confirming what is with
you. Wait, what's going to happen to me
if I don't do that though, Allah? Before
we obliterate Uhoh, that's pretty tough.
Before we obliterate faces, I'm I'm not
kidding you guys. I'm reading this right
here. before we obliterate faces and
turn them upon their backs or curse them
as we curse the Sabbath men and God's
command is done. So what's going to
happen to us if we don't believe in the
Quran which confirms the scriptures that
we have which we should use to uh uh
recognize the Quran and recognize
Muhammad as a prophet. Our faces are
going to get up turned upside down and
we're going to have the same fate as
those who broke the Sabbath. That's how
serious Allah takes this. Jews and
Christians are reprimanded for
distorting their scriptures with their
tongues, lying on the scriptures,
misinterpreting the scriptures, and not
reciting it in truth and obeying it
accurately. In fact, this is chapter 5
68 of the Quran. It says, "Say,
oh people of the book, Jews and
Christians, you do not stand on anything
until you observe the Torah, the Gospel,
and what has been revealed to you from
your Lord." Pretty clear. Allah is
telling me, "I don't have a foundation.
I can't stand on anything if I'm not
observing the Torah, the gospel, and
what has been revealed to me from my
Lord. Let's finish the verse because I
don't want to be accused of taking
anything out of context. And it says,
"And what has been sent down to you from
your Lord will surely increase many of
them in insolence and unbelief. So
grieve not for the people of the
unbelievers." Now, these are all verses
that say that the Quran is confirming
the scriptures. These are verses that
say that we have nothing to stand on.
But the Quran goes a little bit further.
The Quran actually points to the
previous scriptures as the authority on
truth, the standard of truth. You don't
believe me? What's the only thing we do?
We just read. So here's chapter 10 verse
94. Watch what it says. Talking to
Muhammad. So if you are in doubt,
talking to Muhammad, regarding what we
have revealed to you, the Quran, then
ask those who have been reading the
scripture before you. The truth has come
to you from your Lord. So be not OF
THOSE WHO DOUBT. WHAT? HOLD ON a second.
You mean to tell me that Muhammad
himself if he's doubting if if he's
doubting the Quran what's been revealed
to him then he's needs to go to the
people who've been reading the scripture
before him. So then this is what this
this creates. This means cuz doubt means
that you are you don't have the truth
right you're uncertain about the truth
of a thing. So in order to find the
truth, to get certainty, you can go
check with the people of the book who've
been reading the scripture before you.
So this is what it is. So for Muhammad
to get certainty in case he's doubting
what Allah revealed to him in the Quran,
he can go to the people of the book and
then they can show him like, "Yeah, man.
This actually lines up." Then he'll know
that what he's receiving is actually
from God. That means that the reverse is
true. That if he goes to these people
and they showing, "Yeah, no, the Torah
don't say this. No, the gospel don't say
this is this is all contradicted. This
is something different. Then he'll know
that what he's receiving is actually not
from God. So what is the authority? What
is the standard of truth according to
this verse? It's the previous
scriptures, the Bible. Ladies and
gentlemen, the Quran attests to the
authority, inspiration, revelation,
preservation of the Bible. It's as
simple as that. I've never had to lift a
finger. Allah's doing all the work for
me. Again, team Allah just for this
debate. You know what I'm saying? That's
1094. Here's another one, y'all. Watch
what it says here. Yet, this is chapter
28:48.
Yet, when the truth came to them from
ourselves, they said, "Why has he not
been given the the like of that Moses
was given?" Moses was given the Torah,
ladies and gentlemen. Now, this is when
it gets interesting. But they But they
did they not disbelieve also in what
Moses was given a four time? They said a
pair of sorceries mutually supporting
each other. They said we disbelieve in
both. So he's comparing the Quran with
the Torah. And he's saying why hasn't
something like the the Torah come to
you? Why hasn't something like what was
given to Moses come down to you? And
Allah is saying that they disbelieved in
Moses. They're going to disbelieve in
the Quran as well. They they're calling
both books books of sorcery that support
each other. Now watch what the next
verse says.
say, "Bring a book from God that gives
better guidance than these
and follow it if you speak truly." So
Allah is given a challenge. Bring a book
as good as the Torah and the Quran.
What? This is the Torah in Muhammad's
time, ladies and gentlemen. So Allah
issues a challenge to the disbelievers
to bring something as good as the Torah
and the Quran. If what he [snorts] what
he uh uh revealed is not from God, you
bring something better than it then. So
why in the world is the Quran, if the
Torah is corrupted, why is it that Allah
is putting the Torah on the same level
as the Quran and saying bring something
that's as good as these if you can bring
if you can do it. If the Torah is not
authoritative, if the Torah is
corrupted, if the Torah is distorted, if
the Torah doesn't exist anymore, if this
is the case, why is Allah in the seventh
century in Muhammad's time comparing its
goodness, its authoritiveness, its
truthfulness to that of the Quran?
Allah, hey, he's doing his thing in this
Quran, y'all. I'm telling you. Now,
watch this. This is powerful as well.
This is chapter 3, verse 81. This is
this is a good one. This is it's very un
underused. It says this, "And when God
took a covenant with the prophets," now
we as Jews and Christians, we're
familiar with the term covenant, right?
God doesn't turn his back on his
covenants. Now, watch this. It says,
"Now, this is the covenant that I have
given you to the prophets, I've given
you a book and wisdom.
Then there shall come to you a messenger
confirming what is with you.
and you are to believe in him and to
support him. He said, "Do you agree?"
The prophets responded and said, "We do
agree." God said, "Bear witness."
So, and I shall be with you among the
witnesses. So what we have here, ladies
and gentlemen, is that we have Allah and
the prophets coming into an agreement,
building a covenant, making a solid oath
amongst each other. Allah's end of the
bargain is I've given you guys a
scripture. I've given you guys wisdom
with the scripture. Now what I'm going
to do is I'm going to send a messenger
after you to confirm what you have
and you are to help him and support him.
Do you agree? Prophecy is like that
sounds good to us. So according to this
verse, the prophets are supposed to be
able to recognize Muhammad by his
confirmation of what they have. But if
the messenger comes and says, "Hey, what
you guys have is corrupted. What you
guys have is distorted." Then they're
going to be like, "Oh, you're not the
messenger of the covenant. You're not
the one that Allah told us about. You're
a false prophet." So according to the to
the Quran, the determining factor of
Muhammad's prophethood is if he aligns
with what came before him. If he does
not line up with the prophets from
before, if he does not line up with the
books that they had, then Muhammad is a
false prophet according to the covenant
in the Quran.
This is the Quran's covenant, not ours.
We ain't making this up. So according to
the scriptures, according to the Quran,
the authority, the standard of truth is
the previous scriptures.
>> One minute.
>> One minute. Thank you so much. Now let's
talk about what the Islamic dilemma is
not because this is where Jake gets
confused. The Islamic dilemma is not
that the that the Quran uh affirms I'm
sorry that the previous scriptures are a
full legal authority over the Quran.
That's not the Islamic dilemma. When we
say that the Quran affirms the authority
of the previous scriptures, by
authority, we mean that the previous
scriptures are a standard of truth.
That's one. And they are a legal
authority over the Jews and Christians.
They're not a legal authority over the
Muslims. But Jake got that confused,
which is why this is going to be a tough
debate for him. So when you look at what
the Islamic dilemma is and what the
Quran is saying, the the Quran is a
legal authority over the Muslims. the
the uh Torah is a legal authority over
the uh Jews. The gospel is a legal
authority over the Christians. They all
have been given their own law according
to chapter 5:48. That is what the
Islamic dilemma is not.
Thank you.
All right. Now we have Jacob for his
18minut opening statement. Before
you start, Jake, let me make this
announcement. If someone is missing
their car keys, I don't know if someone
lost their car keys. My wife has them at
the check-in desk up there. So, make
sure you have your car keys. If not, go
see my wife. She might have them.
All right, Jake, you got the floor for
18 minutes.
All
right. Can you guys hear me?
All right. I'd like to start off by
thanking Marlin from the Gospel Truth
for hosting tonight's debate. The debate
before us tonight is does Islam teach
the entire Bible is true? Now, we just
heard from Avery about what the Islamic
is Islamic dilemma is and what it's not.
I'm going to have to teach him his own
position and what he has said in the
past. And it's going to be hard. It's
really going to be hard on you today.
So,
here we go. Given this, God Logic is
going to have even more difficult time
than his teacher David Wood had last
weekend. In a recent debate with John
Fontaine, God Logic's teacher David Wood
was asked whether the Quran affirms the
entire Bible or not. David Wood actually
refused to give an answer, a clear
answer to this question, which
demonstrates that even Avery's teacher
doesn't clearly agree with him on
tonight's debate topic. This is because
would and others who use the Islamic
dilemma argument typically make a more
modest claim that the Quran affirms the
Torah, Gospels, and maybe a few other
books in the Old Testament, but it
doesn't necessarily explicitly affirm
the entirety of the Bible. So, this
debate is really Avery versus Jake and
his teacher, David Wood.
However, following the in the footsteps
of his teacher, David Wood, Avery
typically claims that the Quran affirms
the inspiration, preservation, and
authority of the Torah and the Gospels,
as we've just seen him do.
Or in the case of Avery himself, he
argues for the entirety of the Bible.
Avery uses the same verses of the Quran
as David, attempting to justify this
claim.
Okay. As for the verses regarding the
inspiration of the Torah and Injeal, we
agreed that the original revelations
were sent by God. However, the clear the
Quran is clear that Moses and Jesus
received these revelations orally in
their own languages. Quran 14:4 says God
sends messengers in the language of
their people. and Quran 57:27
as well as several other verses
describes the original Injil as a
revelation given to Jesus. This is in
the context of affirming the wholesale
uncorrupted revelations received orally
by Moses and Jesus respectively. The
uncorrupted revelation of the NGO
received by Jesus in his language
doesn't match the gospels or the wider
New Testament corpus written by others
about Jesus in Greek. Avery must clearly
demonstrate from the Quran how the how
the word ineil is used to refer to the
wholesale uncorrupted revelation of the
New Testament. He won't be unable to do
so.
As for the verses used regarding
preservation, although Avery didn't
mention them now, he typically does.
Aver's main argument is that the Quran
states that Allah's words cannot be
changed. But the context of these verses
is that Allah's promises are always
fulfilled. Quran 634 makes this clear
regarding Quran 615. Immabari, a Muslim
scholar says, and I quote, "none can
change his words, i.e., He is saying
that there is no one who could change
what he has informed in his books about
anything which is bound to happen during
its time or has been postponed. It all
happens as Allah says it would. Close
quote. So when Avery says the Quran says
Allah's words cannot be changed, he must
demonstrate that there could never be
textual corruption or revelation. I've
provided a contextually coherent reading
that doesn't require what Avery claims.
He must demonstrate how his reading is
more plausible than mine. Keep in mind
that Avery must demonstrate that the
Quran claims the entire Bible is
preserved, not merely Allah's words in
it. To draw that conclusion, he must
prove that the Quran states the entire
Bible is the word of God, which he will
fail to do.
In addition to citing a lack of positive
evidence for the Bible being the
uncorrupted word of God, there is also
positive evidence in the Quran that
demonstrates previous scriptures have
been textually corrupted. Like Quran 279
when it says that the people of the book
write the book with their own hands and
claim it is from God. This is understood
as textual corruption, not merely
corrupting the meaning of the text.
Interpreting this verse, the companion
Iban Abbas criticizes Muslims for asking
the people of the book about anything
because we have the uncorrupted Quran
while they have corrupted scriptures
with their own hands. Quran 5:13 is
another example of the textual
corruption of previous scriptures
mentioned in the Quran. I can cite other
examples from the Quran and authentic a
hadith to support this claim, but that
should suffice for now.
As for the verses typically used
regarding the supposed authority of the
Bible, which most of this debate is
going to focus on, and I'm gonna have to
teach Avery his own position, they are
numerous. Quran 543-47,
1094, 285, many of which have already
heard are some of the verses typically
mentioned. Oddly enough, much of the
debate typically focuses on the
interpretation of these verses. What is
meant by authority here? That's what
we're going to have to drill down on.
The claim is that the Quran asserts that
the Bible is an authority for Jews and
Christians to follow up until today.
However, Avery claims that it's much
more than that, even though he just
denied it in his opening statement. So,
either he forgot or he's lying. Avery
claims that the Quran states that even
the Prophet Muhammad and all Muslims
must follow the Bible as an ongoing
authority, including its legal rulings.
Now listen to this Avery. I hope you're
going to take notes. In a recent debate
with Daniel Hakikachu when they
discussed Quran 10:94,
Daniel asked, and I quote, "If the
prophet or someone had a doubt about
whether alcohol is prohibited, would
they, i.e. the Muslims, have to go to
the Bible and see, okay, is alcohol
prohibited?" And then based off of that,
take whatever the Bible says. Is that
what you Avery believe in? Close quote.
That's the question from Daniel. Avery
responded by saying, and I quote, "Okay,
matter of fact, let me just answer you
fully. Yes, I do. I do believe that,
i.e. that whatever the Quran says
regarding its legal rulings must match
up with the previous scriptures."
So Avery claims that according to the
Quran 1094 and presumably other verses,
Quranic laws must conform to and agree
with biblical laws. Now, he's already
thrown that out of the window. So maybe
he's going to say that he lost his
debate to Daniel and that he was lying.
I don't know. However, this results in
an absurdity that I call Avery's
authority absurdity. This forms a
dilemma for Avery. According to Quran
10:94, which sets which which set of
laws in the Bible are more authoritative
for Muslims to follow? The Old
Testament, the New Testament, or are
they equal? If you claim that they are
equally legally authoritative for
Muslims to follow, then you get a
contradiction because the Old and New
Testament laws are not the same as
Christians should know, such as dietary
restrictions and divorce laws, just to
name a few. I'll also demonstrate that
this cannot be the Quran's position in
just a moment. On the other hand, if you
claim that either the Old or New
Testament are more authoritative over
over the other for Muslims, then you
have just conceded the dilemma. How
Avery's argument presupposes that the
entire Bible is legally binding upon
Muslims. Once you say that parts of
either the Old or New Testament aren't
legally authoritative for Muslims to
follow today, according to what Avery
said in his debate with Daniel, then you
have embraced the Muslim position. You
also contradict your own reading of
Quran 285 in merely applying some of the
laws from the book, but not all of them.
As a Christian, the answer most
consistent with your theology would be
to say that the New Testament is an
authority over the Old Testament.
Therefore, Muslims should follow the
laws in the New Testament. However, as I
already stated, this results in only
parts of the Bible being authoritative
for Muslims and not the entire Bible,
which means you've just conceded the
debate and the Islamic dilemma. If we
can read Quran 1094 as as merely a
partial affirmation of the Bible's
authority, then we can easily do the
same regarding its inspiration and
preservation. Welcome to the Muslim
position, Avery. I will now provide
positive arguments for the Quran being a
legal authority over Jews and
Christians, just in case he wants to
deny and cop out of what he said in the
debate with Daniel. Let's look at what
in my previous debate I call David's
vimme dilemma. Yes, I am here as the
Jizia collector today. There won't be
communion taken, but there will be Jiza
collected. One of David Wood's top three
verses of the Quran that he says every
Christian must know puts him and Avery
in a dilemma. That is Quran 9:29. It
says, and I quote, "Fight against those
who do not believe in Allah or in the
last day, and who do not consider
unlawful what Allah and his messenger
have made unlawful and who do not adopt
the religion of truth, i.e. Islam, from
those who were given the scripture.
Fight until they give the Jizia
willingly while they are humbled." Close
quote. According to this verse, Islamic
law requires that Jews and Christians
pay the Jiza based upon rejecting Islam
and not accepting what Allah and his
messenger deem prohibited. So if they
were able to simply reject Islamic law,
there wouldn't be this penalty held upon
them. This contradicts Avery's claim
about the Torah and the Gospels being
complete ongoing legal authorities,
whether over Muslims or even over
themselves. Why? It's pretty simple.
Jiza is part of Islamic law. It is not a
legal requirement in the Torah or the
Gospels for Jews and Christians to pay a
tax of Jiza to Muslims. Therefore, the
Quran is obliging Jews and Christians to
follow at least one aspect of Islamic
law instead of the laws in their own
respective scriptures. Notice that one
of the reasons for doing so is precisely
because Jews and Christians refuse to
accept what Allah and his messenger
declare unlawful. In other words, they
must pay the Jiza because they reject
Islamic law. If they were allowed to
reject it according to Avery, then it
wouldn't make any sense. If the Quran
allowed Christians and Jews to rect
reject Islamic law and follow their own
laws for salvation, then this verse
wouldn't make any sense. Okay, as we
continue here, Avery has a dilemma.
Either this me demand is consistent with
his interpretation of authority or it is
not. If Avery says this demand is
consistent with his claim, then he has
conceded the Islamic dilemma is false
because it entails that the Torah and
the Gospels are merely partly authority
authoritative but not entirely. There
are aspects of which the Quran is
authoritative over the previous
scriptures and previous peoples. Well,
that's just what the Muslim position is
that Avery and David have always
criticized. Avery needs to respond to
his own argument regarding Quran 285.
Are you saying that the Quran says you
must only follow parts of your Bible but
not all of it? On the other hand, if
Avery says that this demand is
inconsistent with his claim regarding
the Islamic dilemma and ongoing
authority, then you have also conceded
the Islamic dilemma is false because
it's an admission that this verse
contradicts your ver interpretation of
the Quran.
Okay, I'm not a prophet, guys, but I
will predict what Avery is going to do.
Avery will probably claim that this just
means that the Quran is contradicting
itself. This means that even if I were
to show a verse that verbatim stated,
quote, "The original Torah and Injil are
no longer fully preserved or
authoritative today," Avery would just
say, "This doesn't defeat the Islamic
dilemma, Jake. What are you crazy?
Because it contradicts other verses in
the Quran.
It's not just this verse that
contradicts Avery's claims about ongoing
legal authority, which we've already
seen him change his position in light of
seeing my debate with David, which is
that no, the Torah and the Gospel are
just legally authoritative for Jews and
Christians. But the Quran contradicts
that both in 929 and this next set of
verses. Quran 757 and 158 says, and I
quote, "Those who follow the messenger,
the unlettered prophet, whom they find
written, i.e. described in what they
have of the Torah and the Gospel, who
enjoins upon them what is right and
prohibits them from what is wrong and
makes lawful for them what is good and
forbids them from what is evil and
relieves them of their burden, the
shackles which were upon them. So they
who have believed in him, honored him,
supported him and followed the light
which was sent down with him. It is
those who will who will be the
successful. Say, "Oh Muhammad, oh
mankind," meaning all of you, including
you, Avery, indeed I am a messenger of
Allah to you all. So believe in Allah
and his messenger, the unlettered
prophet who believes in Allah and his
words, and follow him that you might be
rightly guided.
These verses make it abundantly clear
that the Jews and Christians find the
messenger in their scriptures and the
prophet himself is the one who
determines for them what is lawful and
unlawful, not the other way around.
One example of the prophet in the Quran
abregating certain laws for the people
of the book is found in 646.
And to those who are Jews, we prohibited
every animal of uncloven hoof. And of
the cattle and the sheep, we prohibited
to them their fat, except what aderes to
their backs or the endtrails or what is
joined with bone. By that we repaid them
for their transgression. And indeed, we
are truthful. Close quote. These are
dietary restrictions that Allah required
the Jews to follow on account of their
transgression. This is contrasted with
the new dietary laws in the prior verse
that only lists pork as forbidden. Quran
16:124 also mentions that change the
change in Sabbath laws. Says, and I
quote, "The Sabbath was only appointed
for those who differed over it." Close
quote. The Sabbath was only appointed
for a specific group of people. The laws
of the Sabbath and those surrounding it
are no longer required to be followed.
There are plenty more examples of the
Quran intentionally abregating laws from
previous scriptures, but that should
suffice to make the desired point for
now.
Even before the coming of the prophet
Muhammad wasam, parts of the Torah were
already no longer authoritative for the
Jews. In Quran 350, Jesus says to the
Jews, "And I have come confirming what
was before me of the Torah and to make
lawful for you some of what was
forbidden to you. And I have come to you
with a sign from your Lord. So fear
Allah and obey me. Close quote. In this
verse, Jesus is making lawful for the
Jews some of what was previously
forbidden for them. This means some of
the laws of the Torah were no longer
authoritative for the Jews to follow
during Jesus's time. How could the Quran
require the Jews to follow all of the
Torah during the prophet Muhammad's time
if it acknowledges it already abregated
laws from the Torah prior to his coming?
Avery's response results in the
absurdity that the Quran contradicts
itself when it tells believers to follow
the entire Quran while at the same time
it abrogates certain verses within it.
The Quran initially allowed drinking
alcohol and later prohibited it. How
could we follow the entire Quran if some
verses allowed drinking alcohol while
others prohibited it? Let's look at some
biblical examples. Mark 2:7 says that
only God can forgive sins, but John
20:23 says that humans forgive sins.
That's a contradiction. Or even worse,
this demonstrates that the apostles are
themselves gods. A more serious dilemma
would be Matthew 23:1-3,
where Jesus commands people to practice
everything that the Pharisees tell them.
However, Jesus also disagrees how the
Pharisees apply certain laws like
divorce and dietary restrictions.
Another contradiction. Or maybe when
Jesus said you should follow everything
that the Pharisees tell you, he didn't
really mean everything, did he, Avery?
Another dilemma. Avery's interpretation
results in a ridiculously uncharitable
reading of the Quran that entails that
the author of the Quran constantly
contradicts himself, even within the
same sentence. Nobody should take such
reading seriously. The Quran doesn't
blatantly contradict itself if we read
it fairly in context. I invite you all
to do the same. Thank you very much.
>> All right. Now, we'll be entering our
rebuttal portion of this debate. Avery,
your backup for your rebuttal.
>> Testing, testing, testing. All right,
here we go. All right. What did I tell
y'all, man? He said, "This is the Muslim
position. We know, Jake. It's not the
Quran's position. What you're giving us
is not what Allah gives us. Like, I told
you what was going to happen." Now, I
know you say that you're not a prophet.
Well, that was very clear. I'm not a
prophet either, but I'm really good at
predicting my opponent's moves. That's
what's, you know, makes me the chef. So
unfortunately for you, you ended up
quoting uh uh Iban Abbas and who says
that you know who says you know you
shouldn't go and ask the people of the
book anything because they've distorted
their scriptures. So then whose team are
we on guys? Team Allah or team Ian Abbas
because Allah says if you are in doubt
do what? Go and ask those who've been
reading the scripture before you. David
Abbas says don't go ask them. Allah says
go and ask them. I think I'm going to go
ahead and listen to Allah, ladies and
gentlemen. But let's let's be
charitable, right? Let's let's have a
charitable reading of because I don't
think he's doing Ibn Abbas a good favor
here. Um let me read what Ibn Abbas says
elsewhere when he uh gives a a
commentary here in uh chapter 378. Ibn
Abbas um is quoted by Bkari and this is
what he says here. It says Bkari
reported this is there's taps here
quoting Bkari. Bkari reported that Ibn
Abbas said that the ayah means the verse
means that they alter and add although
none among Allah's creation can remove
words from Allah's books.
He says they can remove them from
Allah's books. Iban Abbas in another
place I guess contradicts himself and
says none can remove them from Allah's
books. But what does he say? How do how
do they distort? How do they uh corrupt?
This is what he says. They alter and
distort their apparent meanings.
[snorts] So they are verbally lying on
the scripture, misinterpreting and
misrepresenting the scripture. So if I
was to be charitable to Ibn Abbas, I
would harmonize those two together and
say when he says don't go and ask them
about anything about their books because
they could be lying because they
distorted and corrupted their book and
wrote something with their own hands. I
would say that what Iban Abbas means
when he says they distorted their
scriptures is that they distort their
apparent meanings, not the actual text
because none can remove the words from
Allah's books according to Ibn Abbas. So
either he's contradicting himself or
we'll be charitable and go ahead and
harmonize what I says. Okay. So that's
the that's the that's the first point.
Here's the second thing. He said we
believe in the original scriptures. We
believe in the original revelation that
was given to them. Okay? He hit us with
the we believe rant, y'all. So this is
what I like to give. Um this is what I
like to give him when it comes to the we
believe chant in chapter 20 uh 29. This
is what it says, y'all. Chapter 29:46 it
says, "Dispute not with the people of
the book. Save except in the fairer
manner except for those of them that do
wrong and say,"This is what you say when
you're disputing with the Jews and
Christians." Say, "We believe in what
has been sent down to us and what has
been sent down to you." Uhoh. So, hold
on a second. So, if you're only supposed
to, according to Jake, believe in some
of what we have, well, then does that
mean that you're only supposed to
believe in some of the Quran, too?
Because once again, if the Quran puts
the Quran and our scriptures on the same
level, the same way you believe in the
Quran, you believe in our scriptures. We
believe in what was revealed to us and
what has been revealed to you. So you
can't be believing in part of the
scripture or else you're going to get in
trouble. You got to believe in part of
the Quran as well. I guess according to
Jake. Now again guys, what did I say?
He's going to go ahead give the Muslim
position. We give the Quran. We gave an
explicit verse that says that you're not
allowed to pick and choose what part of
the scripture you believe in and the
parts of the scripture you reject. But
what Jake would have us say is, "No, you
actually can believe in part of the
scripture and reject other parts."
Chapter 2:85.
Do you believe in some of the scripture
and reject the rest? Those who do so
among you are disgraced in this life and
in the hereafter, they're going to go to
hell. I'm going just have that that
verse on replay for the rest of the
debate because I need a verse that says
otherwise, Jake. I need a verse that
says that actually you can pick and
choose what you believe in. and Allah is
going to send you to heaven for that.
That's what I need. I need the opposite
or or give me something to work with,
dude. Now, he also misrepresented me in
my in my debate with Jake. I'm uh I'm
sorry, with Daniel. When Daniel was
cornered by 1094 when he had nowhere
else to go, he was like, "Okay, then
fine. Okay, so then are you saying then
do you believe that if we're in doubt,
if the Muslims are in doubt on whether
or not alcohol is forbidden and or or if
it's allowed that they should go and ask
the people of the scripture?" I said yes
according to what the verse is saying.
This is if they're in doubt about what
the Quran is saying. Not saying that
every ruling of the of the Bible is
binding on the Muslims. However, if
they're in doubt about what the Quran is
saying, they can go get some insight and
some light from the previous scriptures.
That's what the Quran is saying. So,
please don't straw man my position
again. Please don't misrepresent me
because then I got to teach you my
position and teach you yours and teach
you all laws. And we're just doing a lot
of teaching, you know. So let's see what
else he said. Now um he also threw out
um went to to Matthew 23 talks about
this uh oh no not Matthew 23 sorry this
demi dilemma uh where he says that
according to 9:29 uh it is a it is
incumbent upon us to pay the Jizia that
the Quran is forcing the Jiza upon us as
Jews and Christians. Well, you're
absolutely right about that. The Quran
does calls for the subjugation,
humiliation, and the violent fighting of
those who disbelieve among the Jews and
Christians. Thank you for bringing that
verse up, by the way. But unfortunately
for you, Jake, we agree that the Quran
enforces this Jizia law on on the on the
Jews and Christians, this Islamic law.
But according to the Quran, is the Torah
part of Islam? Yes. Is the Gospel part
of Islam? Yes. So the Torah and the
Gospel are Islamic law according to the
Quran. Yes. So of course we're following
Islamic law. Just because you're
bringing me an Islamic law that's been
in the Quran being forced on me does
nothing to the Islamic dilemma. We're
not arguing that the that that the uh
the Muslims have to follow every single
law that's in the Torah or the Gospel. I
told you guys he doesn't know what the
dilemma is, which is why it's going to
be tough. So, in order for you to
actually have a good debate with my
position, learn the dilemma first. We're
not saying that you have to follow every
law within the Bible. What you have to
believe though is that the scriptures
are true. They're authoritative as the
standard of truth. They're legally
binding on the Jews and Christians, but
not on the Muslims particularly. Now,
when it comes to the Jiza, do we have to
uh to to pay the Jizia? Yes. But does
this mean that the scriptures are
corrupted? No. Does this mean that they
didn't have access to the Torah and
Gospel? No. What this means is is
because they rejected Muhammad, because
they chose not to follow the Quran and
follow Muhammad as a prophet, now they
have to because of this, they have to uh
they have to adhere to their scriptures,
follow their scriptures, but pay the
Jiza as well on top of that. Thank you.
All right, Jay Bantella is up for his
eight minute.
Okay, testing.
All right, so guys, we just saw that I
collected my first Jizia from Avery.
Thank you very much. He said that he's
willing to pay the Jiza to the Muslims,
but it's it's quite shocking to me that
he openly lied regarding his debate with
Daniel. So he claims that uh in that
context he's just merely saying right
that if the Muslims have any doubt they
can kind of go and look and see what the
Bible says and uh check what it says
about alcohol being prohibited or not
but they don't have to follow it. But
that's not what he said in his debate
with Daniel. I quoted it earlier and I'm
going to quote it here again in just a
second. So he said, okay, one second
here. I just don't want to misquote him
here. So he said, Daniel asked him,
quote, if the prophet or someone had a
doubt about whether alcohol is
prohibited, would they, the Muslims,
have to go to the Bible and see, okay,
is alcohol prohibited? And then based
off of that, take whatever the Bible
says. Is that what you believe in,
Avery? That is a direct question. Your
answer was okay. Matter of fact, let me
just answer you fully. Yes, I do. Yes, I
believe that. So, you can RETRACT IT,
BUT YOU'RE the one who doesn't know your
own position and you don't understand
what the Islamic dilemma is. But I'm
here to teach you. Don't worry. Have no
fear. Even if even if we granted him and
he said, "Oh, no. I'm backing off, Jake.
I went too far with Quran 1094. I went
too far with that. I'm going to take a
more modest position. I'm going to say
that according to the Quran, Jews and
Christians must follow their own
scriptures, the Torah and the Gospels,
and they are legal authorities over them
as different groups. Well, the vimeie
dilemma takes care of that because what
it shows is at least from a Quranic and
Islamic paradigm is it views our
scriptures as authorities over the Jews
and Christians. It doesn't say that you
can just follow your own laws and you
don't actually have to follow the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him for
salvation. No, the Quran is abundantly
clear. There are literally dozens and
dozens of verses of the Quran requiring
Jews and Christians to believe in the
Quran, to follow the prophet, to follow
the laws that he brought. You're not
allowed to follow your own laws. And
what the dilemma shows is that since you
don't have that law in your Bible
requiring you to pay a tax to the
non-Muslims, that is from our law and it
is being made upon you that you MUST
FOLLOW IT. WELL, I thought the Quran was
okay with just letting you follow your
own laws and that there was no
punishment for that. No, you have to
follow an aspect of Islamic law, which
is the Jizia. One hole in the balloon
and the entire balloon pops. Your
balloon has been popped, Avery. Thank
you for the Jizia. They're going to
start calling me the Jiza collector
after this. I'm no longer going to be
known as the Muslim metaphysician. Thank
you very much. Now, besides that, I
showed you from Quran 6146
where it mentions what was prohibited
for the Jews on account of their
transgression. It contrasts that with
what the Islamic dietary restrictions
are, which is only pork in terms of what
animal we're not supposed to eat. So,
how do you explain that? You can't
appeal to unintentional disagreements.
That's why I think my argument, thank
you very much, is superior to the uh
intentional edits argument which I also
brought forward. Okay, it's better
because you can't say it's
unintentional. You can't say that the
disagreement or difference is
unintentional. Why? Because Allah in the
Quran is actually citing their laws and
saying that it disagrees with them and
it's requiring them, the Jews and the
Christians, to follow Islamic law.
That's why I know it's it's hard on the
musher, but it's going to be all right,
bro. You'll be you'll be okay. Trust me,
you're going to learn something out of
this. And all of the other Christians
are going to learn about the Islamic
dilemma as well. His own friend, David
Wood, after getting thrashed on this
aspect, said, "Well, you know what,
Jake? We could just throw authority out
of the mix. We could just remove
authority and say, "No, no, no. We're
just going to run the Islamic dilemma
off of inspiration and preservation."
I'll admit you could do that, but it
would be a massive, massive concession.
Why? Because you've been using the
authority part, David Wood, and others.
You're new in the game, but they've been
doing it a lot longer for 20 plus years.
They've been running the same argument,
saying that the Quran allows them, the
Jews and the Christians, to follow their
own scriptures for legal authorities.
That the Quran is not legally an
authority over and binding upon them.
ONCE YOU ADMIT THAT you're wrong about
that, 543 44 45 46 47 48 568 1094 YOUR
FAVORITE 285 ALL OF THESE different
verses which are typically quoted in
support of the authority section for
Christians with the Islamic dilemma go
out the window. So Avery, maybe you want
to do that. I don't know. But David Wood
was actually hypothesizing that and
said, "You know what? Maybe we should
actually remove the authority part."
Why? Because Jake has completely busted
their entire argument, shown that
Islamic law and the Quran are actually a
legal authority over Jews and Christians
and their scriptures. And in that case,
all of those verses, your favorite
verses in Ma 5:es 43-48 about judging by
as a legal authority over for the Jews
and Christians, that's gone. Now, now
once you admit that in 1094 is gone and
285, your beloved f one of your favorite
texts, that is a massive admission. And
I'm not going to let go on this point.
Why? Because from my pos position, I
think the most clear the most clear
thing regarding this debate is that the
Quran views itself as a legally binding
authority over Jews, Christians and
non-M Muslims uh in in the greater
context and requires them to follow our
prophet, his laws and our scriptures
that we've come with basically regarding
authority in the Islamic dilemma. It's a
debate over whether or not the Quran
teaches perennialism. If you don't know
what perennialism is, it's the idea that
there could be other religions and other
pathways to God and they can be followed
in order to have salvation. But guess
what? That's not what the Quran teaches.
Avery backed away from his more
ridiculous claim that Muslims must
follow the Torah and Injeal, which forms
his own uh absurd dilemma for legal
authority. But even if we grant him that
and say no no no Quran is saying that
the Jews and Christians each follow
their own respective scriptures and yet
they can still have salvation. This is
basically perennialism and your claim is
that or at least entails that the Quran
teaches perennialism. Now what's clearer
from my perspective? This is something I
will actually admit. I don't have a
problem saying this. I believe that the
Quran does teach textual corruption of
the previous scriptures. But I think
it's even more clear and more abundant
in terms of the number of verses and
clarity that come along with it that the
Jews and Christians must follow Islam,
must follow the Quran and the prophet
Muhammad in order to have salvation.
Avery cannot deal with those points and
that's why I've had to come and collect
my Jizia. Thank you very much.
>> That's time. Thank you so much.
All right, we are about to enter the
fire round of cross examination. So,
this should be fun. Uh, both of these
guys put on a great show so far. Uh,
this cross-examination will be a total
of 40 minutes. Uh, both parties will get
20 minutes each to ask questions. And,
uh, before we start the cross text, I
want to remind everyone once again, uh,
we do have index cards back there. Uh,
and if you want to, if you have a
question, write that question down, get
it in the little basket back there, and
so we can have a a fantastic Q&A at the
end of this debate. Uh, with that said,
Avery, you're up first for your
20-minute cross-examination of Jake. And
I'll start your time as soon as you
begin to ask your first question.
>> Testing, testing, testing, testing.
Thank you. Appreciate it. Uh, Jake, you
believe that Jesus is going to come
back, right?
>> Yes.
Okay. Uh what's he going to do? Give us
a couple descriptions if you can.
>> Uh there are numerous hadith about it. I
don't know what have you have in mind
specifically but he's going to come and
the different hadiths speak about him
breaking the cross killing the pigs
which is symbolic of actually uh the
fact that Jews and Christians um sorry
Christians are actually not properly
following the correct law and they're
eating pig and they're essentially
worshiping the cross but that's one
aspect and he's going to come under the
Sharia under the laws of the prophet
Muhammad and call people to guidance.
>> Awesome. Um, you missed one. Um, what's
he going to do about [clears throat] the
Jiza?
>> Sorry.
>> What's he going to do about the Jizia?
>> The Jizia at that time will no longer be
valid because of the fact,
>> let me let me finish. The Jizia the Jiza
at that particular moment in time will
no longer be valid because of the fact
that the it's too late and the people
either accept Islam or they don't. Those
are the only two options at that point.
So you agree that Jesus is going to be
the one that abolishes the law of Jizia?
>> No.
>> No. Jesus Jesus is going to come and at
the time when he comes because it's the
end times, the Jiza is no longer
applicable. That doesn't help with your
Islamic dilemma. You got to try harder,
bro.
>> I'm going to ask you one last time. I'm
going to give you a chance before I
bring this up. Yeah. Go ahead.
>> Is Jes according to the hadith, does
Jesus abolish the Jizia? Yes, sir.
>> No. It's Allah who abolishes the Jiza.
It's Allah who abolishes the Jiza and
Jesus is sent as a prophet. We don't
believe that the prophet Jesus is making
his own laws independent of Allah. Thank
you.
>> Okay, I got you. So, we're going to go
to the hadith really quick and I want to
just bring this up for you because you
said according to the Hadith, Jesus is
not the one who is abolishing the Jiza.
So
>> I said that prophets I said that
prophets when they bring laws they are
receiving revelation from God and based
upon that that's the laws that they're
bringing.
>> I got you. So I'm going to ask it again.
Does
>> it does Jesus abolish the Jizia? Yes or
no?
>> I already answered that. I said that the
prophet Jesus and all prophets receive
revelation and based upon that they
bring laws. But even if even if you
wanted to say that Jesus came and
independently
abolished a Jiza, that would not help
you at all whatsoever in the Islamic
dilemma. Okay, here's Sahib Bukari 2476.
This is one of many, ladies and
gentlemen. It says, and I'm going to ask
this in the question narrated Abu
Herrera. Allah's apostle said, "The hour
will not be established until the son of
Mary descends amongst you as a just
ruler. He will break the cross, kill the
pigs, and abolish the jizzy attacks.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> So, does the law that Jesus when Jesus
is coming, is he, according to what I
just read, going to abolish the jizzy
attacks?
>> As I said, he is doing it based upon
revelation. So, he is doing it.
>> He's doing it based upon revelation. And
that doesn't change anything. You have
to establish.
>> I bet it doesn't. We just getting
started, man.
point. You have to explain how it
changes anything related to the Islamic
dilemma.
>> We're going to but this is you haven't
shown anything.
>> The point is your your argument does not
touch the Islamic dilemma. But I'm
obliging. Okay. We're going to see.
Okay. We're going to see. So Okay. We're
going to get busted up.
>> Okay. Okay. Cool. So according to you,
this is a slow this is a slow
>> slow simmer. Exactly. IT'S SIMMERING TOO
SLOW. WE DON'T EVEN know this is.
>> So according to you according to you
smell you just contradicted yourself. I
didn't you contradicted yourself. I know
you're slow but Hold on. Hold on. Let me
>> ask a question. BRO JUST TALKING. AND
YOU HAVE TO ASK.
>> All right, guys. Guys, guys, guys, guys.
All right, ask a question.
>> Come on now. Get the question out,
Avery. Let's go.
>> All right. So, according to what you
just said, you contradicted yourself and
said that Jesus does pay the uh does
abolish the Jizia tax through revelation
that God gives him. Okay,
>> I said that from the beginning. Where's
the contradiction?
>> So, here's my question. Here's my Well,
we we mind the tape.
>> Exactly. I said it from the beginning.
>> Here's my question. Okay. So when Jesus
comes and abolishes the jizzy attacks,
does that mean that his revelation is an
authority over the Quran?
>> NO.
>> OH. SO, SO uh uh by bringing a new law
or abregating a law in the previous
revelation does not mean that this new
revelation is now an authority over the
previous.
>> No. Because this was foretold since the
beginning. The hadith that's mentioned
over the hadith that's mentioned. Yeah.
It's over for you because you don't you
still don't understand your own
argument. It's so pathetic. It's so
pathetic.
>> Jesus get the book out for you.
>> Jesus Yeah. Jesus is receiving
revelation. Jesus is receiving
revelation. And at that time, the Jizia
is no longer prescribed. It's no longer
an option for humanity to actually take.
That's the point.
>> Got it. So, just to make sure I got it
all down. What's the
>> Yeah, get it all down. Go ahead.
>> All right. So, we got that. Uh,
>> can we get a question here? Are we going
to get a question?
>> Let's let's get a question. A, let's get
a question.
>> All right. Thank you. All right. So, it
looks like we got rid of the the whole
authority type of thing and Jizia uh
dilemma.
>> No, we haven't.
>> So, my my my question is this now. Um,
according to chapter 3:81, you agree
that Allah [snorts] made a covenant with
the prophets, right?
>> Yeah.
>> And the covenant was that he has given
them a book and has given them wisdom.
And um on Allah's end of the bargain,
he's going to send a messenger that
confirms what they have. Correct.
>> Uh I don't have it up before me. Uh I'm
just pulling it up now.
>> You don't memorize it? You don't
memorize?
>> No, I don't have the entire Quran
memorized. Do you?
>> Oh, another one that doesn't memorize
it.
>> Do you?
>> I don't think so.
>> Uh yeah. It says, "And recall of the
prophets when Allah took the covenant of
the prophet saying, "Whatever I give you
of the scripture and wisdom, and then
there comes to a messenger confirming
what is with you, you must believe in
him and support him." Allah said, "Have
you acknowledged and taken upon my co
commitment?" They said, "We have
acknowledged it." He said, "Then bear
witness and I am with you among the
witnesses."
>> So the Allah's end of the bargain is to
send a messenger that confirms what they
have. Correct.
>> Right. And you must including you, the
people of the book, must believe in him
and support him.
>> Very good. How do they recognize this
messenger?
>> In their scriptures and based upon one
way is based upon their scriptures. And
there's also independent evidence in
terms of miracles, prophecies, and other
things.
>> In the course of the covenant, how do
they recognize it? Please. It's right in
there in the verse. You just read it.
>> Yeah. It says, "Whatever I give you of
the scripture and wisdom, and then there
comes to a messenger confirming what is
with you. You must believe in him and
support him." Show me in the verse where
it actually says, "That's the reason
why."
>> That's not supposed to be your
>> Exactly. you you It's not there.
>> So, hold on a second. So, according to
the to the verse, the messenger is going
to come confirming what they have.
Correct. Exactly. Confirming what is
with you.
>> I got you. So now and as a result
they're supposed to believe in him and
support him. Correct.
>> That's part of it. Yep.
>> Okay. So if a messenger comes and
contradicts what they have, will they
have grounds to judge that messenger as
a false messenger?
>> Uh the people of the book.
>> Yes. The people the
>> people the people of the book if they
have genuine scripture that disagrees
with what what a uh prophet after them
comes with then yes. According to the to
381, do they have the genuine scripture?
>> No, they do not.
>> So they're they do not.
>> So I got you. So according to the
scripture [laughter]
according to chapter
>> I know you got to laugh because you
don't have question. I'm just trying to
get questions. So according to chapter 3
verse 81, Allah is sending a messenger
to confirm corrupted books.
>> No, he's confirm he's coming to actually
as the bring the foran which
distinguishes what is in them.
>> Why does it say bring the foran? What
>> where does it say bring the forkan
there? It's mentioned all throughout the
Quran.
>> Okay. Well, it says the Torah forces.
Who cares? I'm talking about this verse
right here, Jake. According to the
verse, he's supposed to confirm. It
means it means that it is something
which distinguishes between truth and
falsehood,
>> which the Quran says the Torah is.
That's what the Quran is actually doing.
It's distinguishing between truth and
falsehood over the previous scriptures.
>> That's not my question though because
no, the Quran doesn't say that. But it
says the Torah is the criterion in the
foran as well that also decides what's
true and what's false, what's right and
what's wrong as well. That's chapter
21:48. My question about this verse is
according to this verse, it says that
the messenger is going to come
confirming what they have. Does that
mean that what they have is true
scripture?
>> Not all of it. No.
>> So then he's going to be confirming
corrupted books.
>> No. He's going to be confirming he's
going to be confirming what is correct
and he's going to be disagreeing with
what what is incorrect as he explicitly
does all throughout the Quran.
>> I got you. Okay. So, in chapter 3 81
when it says that there that they're
going to he's going to come and he's
going to confirm what's with them.
You're saying that what's with them is
partially true and partially uh
corrupted. Is that right? Just as Quran
350 says that Isaam or Jesus is going to
come and confirm the Torah while at the
same time he actually abregates laws
from it. So it's not a total
confirmation in the way that you
imagine.
>> I got you. So when the Quran you you
agree that the Quran abrogates itself,
correct?
>> Uh yeah, in certain circumstances.
>> Okay. And so in circumstances when the
Quran abrogates that guys, abrogation
means when the Quran is bringing a a new
law or something else to substitute
another verse. So when the Quran comes
and abregates its own verses, is the
Quran saying that the Quran is partially
true and partially false?
>> No, it's saying that it's saying that
it's partially authoritative. It's not
fully authority.
>> I got you. So there's some verses.
>> Check the argument, buddy.
>> You're not tracking the argument.
>> So So according So according to even
abrogation, it's still affirming that
the entire thing is true. Correct.
>> It could be true, but laws from it can
be abregated, which you haven't dealt
with at all.
>> Oh yeah, I got you. So things can be
true the even though certain laws are
not binding anymore. Correct.
>> Yes.
>> So just because abrogation comes doesn't
mean that what what is being abregated
is false or corrupted. Correct.
>> And I never said that. That meant THAT
>> THAT'S WHAT YOU ARGUE. NEVER SAID THAT.
What are we doing?
>> I KNOW YOU'RE A LITTLE BIT SLOW, BRO,
BUT YOU'RE going to catch us by the end
of it.
>> Allah give me
I know
>> you can't catch on. When did I ever say
that abrogation equaled corruption?
never said that.
>> I got you. So, so
>> I know you're slow, but David and Shimon
are too. They can't catch up.
>> You gonna have to watch your clip back
after.
>> Yeah, you're gonna have to watch it when
I never said that abrogation meant
corruption. Never said that. In fact, I
explicitly denied it. Try to keep up,
bro. You can't keep up with the
argument.
>> I got you. So, according to the verses
that you've been bringing up in your
authority argument, 9:29,
you would agree does not prove
corruption of the previous scripture.
Correct?
>> I never said that. It does. It proves
that your scripture is not legally
authoritative over us. Number one, and
number two, that our scripture is
legally authoritative over the Jews and
Christians and your previous scriptures.
Can you actually deal with the argument?
>> Well, the actual argument today, Jake,
is the Islamic dilemma. And telling me
that the Bible is not fully legally
binding on the Muslims or the Musl the
Quran is legally binding on the on the
Christians is not the Islamic dilemma.
So my question So my question is in
regards to the Islamic dilemma. Do you
actually have AN ARGUMENT THAT ADDRESSES
THE ISLAMIC DILEMMA?
>> YEAH. I'm going to again have to teach
you your own argument when you spoke to
Danny Boy and you said that the Muslims
actually have to check with the Jews and
scriptures uh Jews and Christians and
their previous scriptures to see whether
or not alcohol is prohibited. And based
upon that, we have to accept whatever it
says. So you're caught. You've had to
change your own argument because you
can't deal with my argument.
>> No, I what I have to do is correct you
on a misrepresentation. Like the verse
says, it's ask those if you are in
doubt. If they're in doubt about what
the Quran says, does it only partially?
>> It says what the Quran what has been
revealed to them.
>> Is it only partially what's been
revealed?
>> Is it partially or fully?
>> What's been revealed?
>> That's not your question. What's been
revealed?
>> What's been revealed to the Jews and
Christians?
>> No. No. when it says, "If you are in
doubt about that which we have revealed
to you." Thank you. So, okay. So,
according to the Quran, if they're in
doubt about what the Quran says, what
are they supposed to do?
>> Exactly. So, now you're going back and
you're restating you're restating.
You're restating your own argument,
which is that according to you, those
previous scriptures are legally
authoritative for Muslims over the
Quran. Correct. If they do not So you're
asking me a question. You can ask me
that on your time. But let me just
>> because you're not dealing WITH THE
ARGUMENT.
>> WE'LL SEE. SO according to 1094, right?
According to the 1094, can you tell what
what does doubt mean? What does it mean
to doubt?
>> To not know something to be true.
>> Correct. Okay, that's awesome. And so if
Muhammad did not know something to be
true in the Quran, what does Allah tell
him to do to get certainty of the truth
about what the Quran is saying? It's not
only speaking to the prophet Muhammad,
it's speaking more generally to Muslims
to go to go to the people of the book
who were reading the scriptures. And if
you look at, let me finish. If you look
at the tapsiers, if you look at our
classical authorities who actually have
an authority, unlike you, we don't care
about your taps. Sorry to tell you. It
says it's to go to the people who
actually understood the truth of Islam
from their scriptures who actually
became Muslims. That's the position.
>> I got you. And what were those people
reading?
>> Those people were reading the previous
scriptures.
>> Thank you. So all that all that flub
didn't matter. So they did. So when it
comes here's my question. Now watch
this. So according to the the verse for
Muhammad to get certainty of the truth,
he has to go ask those people who
converted to Islam who are reading the
previous scripture. So if he goes to
these people and he sees that what he's
receiving in the Quran lines up with
what they have, then he'll be certain of
the truth of what he was doubting in the
Quran. Correct.
>> The Quran in that context, let me
finish. In that context, if you read the
prior verses, it's talking about the
stories of the prophets and the
hardships that they went through. No
worries. And let me finish. And the
prophet peace be upon him was to go to
recognize that the same thing was taking
place for previous prophets. It's not
all encompassing.
>> Okay, no worries. So, let's your claim
is no worries. For the sake of argument,
let me go with you that it's not
all-encompassing for those particular
things. For the sake of the argument
right here, you got to let me get it
out. You're wasting my time. I have to
follow part of the waste of my time. Ask
a question.
>> Okay. So, stop interrupting. Relax.
>> You keep you keep commenting.
>> I like when my food talks back to me,
but this is tough.
>> All right. Go ahead. Go ahead and ask
your question.
>> All right. Thank you. So then, so you
said yes that if Muhammad goes and
checks with these people and he sees
that what he's receiving in the Quran
lines up with what they've been reading
in their in their books, then he'll know
that what the Quran is saying is true.
So this means that the opposite is true
as well, right? That if he goes to them
and he sees that what he what he uh what
he's doubting is not in line with what
they have, then he'll know that what he
is receiving is not the truth. Correct.
>> Give me the inference rule for that.
>> So I can you answer the question?
>> No, not necessarily. It doesn't follow
logically.
>> I got you. So
>> it doesn't I know you got to learn cuz
you don't know you don't know what
actually follows and what doesn't.
>> So So you're saying that it it works one
way but it doesn't work the other way.
>> It doesn't necessarily work the other
way. You have to show and give an
argument for that which you haven't
provided.
>> So when I when I
>> You're the one talking over me, right?
Every time I answer the question.
>> No, you're I'm in the middle of asking
the question.
>> No, I was answering and you keep
interrupting.
>> All right. So you done with your answer?
>> Yeah, I'm done.
>> Okay. All right. [laughter]
So just like you said it's you said yes
if he goes to them and sees that what he
has lines up with what they what they
have then he'll know that he has the
truth. That means that the inverse is
true that if he goes to them and sees
that it doesn't line up with what they
have then he'll know that it is false.
Correct.
>> Wrong. What is the inference rule for
that? Can you provide it?
>> It's okay if
>> you can. I know. I know. Yeah. It's not
your It's not your cross. It's not your
cross. It's all being exposed. It's all
good. Yeah, it is.
>> So, so then earlier you said that if the
messenger came and disagreed with what
they had, didn't confirm what they had,
then they will be a they will rightfully
be able to judge him as a false prophet.
Correct? You said that earlier, right?
>> Ask it again. Sorry.
>> You said say it again.
>> Yeah, I didn't hear the question.
>> Okay. You said earlier that you answered
yes. If according to 381, if they uh a
messenger comes and contradicts what
they have, then they then they will have
the right to judge him as a false
messenger. Correct?
>> No. What I said was what I said I know
you want to take your Lord you want to
take your Lord's name in vain in the
church. I understand he's Lord. I know.
Let me finish. I said if according to
what is genuine revelation which they
know to be genuine revelation that if
someone else comes and contradicts it
doesn't matter who or what they're
bringing then yes they would be deemed
false.
>> How do they know if it's genuine
revelation?
>> How do they know what
>> if it's genuine revelation?
>> They know if it's genuine revelation
based upon what they received and based
upon what THE PROPHET WHAT
>> GUYS based upon what the prophet is
coming with. He's able to tell them if
you believe if you believe that he is a
genuine messenger of God which you
quoted earlier that the Jews and
Christians must believe in the Quran
well then they have to also see what the
Quran says in matching with their
supposed scriptures.
>> I got you. Thank you. All right. In
chapter 21 29 verse uh 46 it says to not
dispute with the people of the book
except in fairness um and to say to them
that we believe in what was revealed to
us and what was revealed to you. So my
question is um according to that verse
do they have to believe in part of what
they have?
>> Uh it says do not argue with the people
of the book except in the best way. What
does it have to do with anything? Can
you go to the part where it says say we
believe in what was revealed to us and
what is revealed to you?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, according to the verse, do
they have to are they uh are they able
to believe in part of what they have?
>> They're referring to the genuine
revelation that the people of the book
had.
>> So, is that a yes?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, that so it uses it in the same
context as the Quran. Believe in what
what was revealed to us, which is the
Quran. Correct.
>> Uh part of it. Yeah.
>> Oh, so you could believe in part of the
Quran. No, you're you're missing the
point. What is revealed? What is
revealed to you? The prophet peace be
upon him received the Quran and other
revelation besides that. So Quran is
only part of the re
>> when he when it says when you're
disputing with the people of the book
say we believe in what was revealed to
us. Is that the Quran?
>> We believe in that which has been
revealed to us and revealed to you. It's
talking about it's talking about the
previous scriptures or revelation that
the people of the book received and what
the prophet received is the Quran and
the Sunnah.
>> All right. So, stop wasting my time with
that thing.
>> I already
got you. So, according to the verse, are
you able to believe according to the
verse, are you able to believe in part
of the Quran?
>> No.
>> So, then according to the verse, you're
not able to believe in part of what was
revealed to them, right?
>> Exactly.
>> Oh, it's over. Hey, man. Hey, thanks for
coming, man.
>> I never said that.
>> Thanks for coming.
>> Yeah, thanks for coming.
>> It's over. Hey, I I I relaxed my time
and you can give him the rest. It's
over.
>> It's over.
>> It's over for you. I know. It's over.
>> It's a done deal.
>> Yep, it is.
>> All right, guys. Uh let's let's settle
down. Hold your applause. And uh so
we're going to um so you're you're going
you're you're relinquishing the rest of
your time. Avery, you good?
>> Oh, yeah. It's over, bro.
>> All right.
>> Give it to him.
>> All right. So Jake is up for his
20-minute cross-examination of Avery.
And I'll start your time, Jake, as soon
as you begin to ask your first question.
>> Okay. When you use the Islamic dilemma
and you say that the Quran affirms the
authority of the previous scriptures,
what does authority mean?
>> It means that it is the standard of
truth and it is legally binding on the
Jews and Christians.
>> Okay. It's legally binding on the Jews
and Christians. So, if I can show to you
in the Quran that the Quran and Islamic
law is binding on Jews and Christians,
then that defeats your claim. Correct?
>> No.
>> Oh, it doesn't?
>> Nope. [laughter]
So you just said that the authority part
means that the Jews and Christians must
follow their scriptures as legal
authorities. Are they required to follow
the Quran as legal authority?
>> Yes, they are.
>> They are.
>> Okay. So they're they're required to
follow, listen to this, the Jews and
Christians are required to follow the
Quran as a legal authority and they're
also required to follow the Torah and
Niel. Correct?
>> Yeah. So let me qualify this when I say
this. So [laughter] so according to you
contradicted yourself.
>> No I didn't. It's a both and not an
either or. So according to the Quran the
Jews and Christians are supposed to
follow Muhammad and the Quran while also
believing in their scriptures as well.
However, because they reject Muhammad as
a prophet and reject the Quran. The
Quran says in chapter 5 43 all the way
to 48. It says for the Jews judge by the
Torah. Why did they come to you Muhammad
when they have the Torah? For in verse
47, let the people of the gospel judge
by what Allah has revealed in there. In
chapter 40, in verse 48, it says, "To
each of you, we have given you your own
law. And if Allah wanted to make you one
nation, he would have, but he didn't do
it."
>> Okay? So, you're contradicting yourself
because you're saying you're you're
saying to yourself that in 548, the Jews
and Christians are supposed to follow
their own laws, but now you're saying
they're supposed to follow their own
laws and the Quran. How can they follow
their own laws and the Quran when the
Quran explicitly abregates their laws?
Okay. So again, you're not listening to
what I'm saying. The Quran requires them
to believe and follow uh Muhammad and
the Quran. Yeah.
>> However, they don't. When they don't,
Allah says, "Okay, well, you can judge
by your Torah, then judge by your gospel
since you're disbelieving in the
prophet." So because So they're required
to believe in Muhammad and they're told
to follow him. But when they reject, he
says, "Fine. Follow the Torah and the
Gospel. This is your legal uh legal
binding on you."
>> Okay. So, can they follow the Torah and
the Injil as legal authorities to get to
paradise according to the Quran?
>> Uh, according to chapter 2, yes.
>> According to chapter 2. Yeah. So, on the
one hand, on the one hand, you're saying
that the Quran is requiring the Jews and
Christians to follow the Quran as a
legal authority, but they don't actually
have to. That's contradictory.
>> No, you asked, do they have to to make
it into paradise? So what I'm saying is
is that if even when they're following
their own laws, following the gospel and
the Torah, they also still have to
believe in the Quran and Muhammad as a
revelation even if they're not uh bound
by
>> do they have to follow his laws?
>> Uh so they are told to follow the I mean
>> what are they why are they required to
follow his laws? For what?
>> I already told you this.
>> For what? Why are they required to
follow his laws?
>> I'll say it again. Because he was a
prophet. He's the messenger that God
sent to them and that's confirming what
they have. So he tells them follow him
what he forbids uh you know abide by
that what he doesn't forbid abide by
that when they don't Allah still gives
them a caveat okay judge by the Torah
then that's why he says when they try to
come to Muhammad for judgment he said
why do they come to you for judgment
when they have the Torah in which
Allah's judgment is in he's giving them
a caveat when they reject the Quran
>> okay so when they reject the Quran and
don't follow Islamic law. Are they going
to be held accountable for that?
>> Uh if by rejecting the Quran, yes, if
they're So, what they have to do is even
if they're not following, let me finish.
>> Not following. Let me finish. Even if
even if they're not uh bound by the
legal laws of the Quran,
>> you just said they were still
>> You're not listen You're not even
listening what I'm saying.
>> You just said they were.
>> You're not listening.
>> You're contradicting yourself.
>> Okay. So, you you can you explain how I
contradicted myself? You keep saying you
keep saying that the Quran says that the
Jews and Christians actually have to
follow the Quran as a legal authority
but when they don't then they're
supposed to follow their Torah and I
asked you why is it the case that they
are supposed to follow the Quran for
Islamic rulings and legal rulings to
begin with? Why are they being asked to
do that? You said well because they're
supposed to follow the prophet and his
laws. Why? You're not answering the
question.
>> I did answer the question. I'll say it
again. Listen slowly. Muhammad was sent
as a prophet confirming what they have.
So because he's a fulfillment of what
they have, they are to believe in him,
support him, and follow him. That's what
the Quran says. However, when they don't
follow the Quran and its legal bindings,
Allah gives them a caveat. You can have
the Torah. You can have the Gospel.
while the Muslims have the Quran.
Chapter, let me finish. Chapter 5:48.
Well, I'm answering you. You said I
didn't answer. So, chapter 5:48 makes it
clear for you, uh, uh, Jake. It says,
"If we wanted to, we could have made you
all one nation, but to each of you, we
have given to you your own law." So,
according, if I'm contradicting myself,
I guess Allah is cuz I'm just quoting
him.
>> Exactly. So here when they refuse to
follow Islamic law, the Jews and the
Christians, are they doing something
wrong?
>> Repeat that. Sorry.
>> When the Jews and Christians refuse to
follow Islamic law, are they doing
something wrong? According to the Quran,
>> they they are doing something wrong. If
they are rejecting, if that is in line
with them rejecting him as a prophet as
a whole, as revelation,
>> I I asked I'm going to ask again. I know
it's hard on the Musher King. I know
it's hard on the Musher King asked an
answer. The question is, are they doing
something wrong when they refuse to
follow the Quran for Islamic rulings,
Islamic laws?
>> I'll answer it again.
>> You didn't answer. Go ahead. Try again.
>> I guess I'll repeat.
>> Try again. I know it's hard on you. I
know. Maybe Let me not repeat it three
times. We know Allah says, "Don't say
things." Go ahead. So according to the
Quran, it says that they are to follow
Muhammad because they're supposed to
recognize him from their scriptures. If
they don't recognize him as a prophet
from God and therefore do not follow the
legal bindings, then they are doing
something wrong. However, if they choose
to obey their own scriptures and still
believe that Muhammad is a re is a
prophet from God and the Quran is a
revelation, that is not wrong. They're
okay.
>> Okay. So, they're okay if they follow
the Quran for Islamic rulings, but they
they're not allowed to reject the
Quran's rulings. Correct.
>> It's a revelation from God.
>> Okay. So, they can believe it's
revelation, but say, "We don't want to
follow revelation. We stick to our
>> So in Quran 285 when it says that the
Jews in that case they believe in part
of a book part of the book and
disbelieve part of the book. Was that in
regards to them choosing to follow part
of the book and not follow another part
of the book?
>> Yeah. So according to them it was
binding on them the Torah. So it's it's
it's like this. When Jesus
>> were they following part of the book?
>> Hold on.
>> Were they only following part of the
book?
>> Can I answer your first?
>> Yeah. Try to answer. All right. You
interrupting me. You gohead. Okay. Thank
you such a gentleman. So when you're
saying when when it says that they are
uh uh disobeying a law and then uh
accepting another law, they're believing
in part of the book and rejecting other
parts of the book, right? Following one
law while rejecting another law, that's
that both are uh binding on them. Now
just because something is abregated
let's say doesn't mean that oh because
it's abregated because a new law has
come and let's say superseded the
previous one it doesn't mean that they
don't believe in the one that was
superseded. They believe in that past
law it's just no longer binding. That
doesn't mean that they're believing in
part of scripture and following it now.
>> Is is in the context is belief have
anything to do with them following?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So good. So they're not supposed
to. So in the concept of Quran 285 when
you say it's they're believing in Jake
is believing in a part of the book and
disbelieving in part of the book in that
context it's about following. Now you
Mr. Avery are advocating that Christians
and Jews are allowed to follow parts of
the Quran but also not follow parts of
the Quran. So how is 285 not applying to
you?
>> Because you're misconstring the two
contexts. Yeah, [laughter] you're
laughing. I know it's hard on you. I
know it's tough. This is why you have to
interrupt me when I answer. This is why
you got to interrupt me when I answer.
>> You started talking about me.
>> I started talking and you interrupted.
Go ahead. Go ahead. It's all good. You
know, this this doesn't work.
>> I know. So, according to 285, it's about
them and what is binding on them. Do you
get that? It's what's binding on them.
So, they can't pick and choose in the
Torah what they choose to follow and
what they uh choose to to to reject.
They can't do that. When you go to
another context that you're equivocating
on, it doesn't work the same way because
it's not talking about what's binding on
them. According to the Quran, what's
binding on the Jews is the Torah. What's
binding on the Christians is the Gospel.
Let me finish the Quran. Allow me to
finish, please. Go ahead. I appreciate
it. You're taking long. I appreciate
you. Ask me a question, man. You're
taking long. You're taking It takes long
to teach. This is my time.
>> It does take long to teach.
>> This is my time.
>> Well, okay. I'm sorry. Just let me give
me like 45 more seconds. Go ahead. Come
on.
>> I appreciate it. So, with with with this
being said, when you're when we're
talking about uh when you're talking
about believing in part of the scripture
and rejecting the rest, you're not
talking about what's legally binding on
on the a Christian as what is true.
Like, they're saying this is true, this
is false, this is true, this is false.
That's wrong to do in their scriptures.
They can't do that with the Quran. They
have to believe all the Quran is true,
even though not all of the Quran is
binding on them legally.
>> Okay. So, now we're going back. You're
flip-floppy once again. an argument for
the Islamic dilemma.
>> You're flip-flopping once again. Is the
entire Quran legally binding upon Jews
and Christians?
>> I'll answer it again.
>> You have You just flip-flopped. You just
said no.
>> I'll answer it again. The Jews and
Christians are initially called to
follow Muhammad and the Quran. When they
don't, they are called to still follow
and abide by the laws in their
scriptures. However, like the verse you
pulled up, they have to pay the Jizia.
This is why they are giving given this
but not for example the polytheist. The
polytheist is convert or die. Christians
are convert or pay the Jiza and keep
your scriptures right. And if they pay
pay the Jiza, is that acceptable? Okay.
In terms of them following the Quran in
order to make it to paradise.
>> Sure,
>> it is. Where do you get that from?
>> Okay. According to the Quran, it says
those who believe among the Jews and
Christians have nothing to fear, they're
going to go to paradise. So even though
they're they're uh if they're uh
following their their scriptures
correctly and they're following I mean
they're not believing in it part of it
partially, rejecting it partially,
they're believing in their scriptures
and they don't reject it partially and
they don't reject Muhammad as a prophet
and the Quran as a revelation, they're
good to go. That's chapter two. So when
when the Quran says and you just said
that they have to accept Muhammad as a
prophet. Yeah.
>> Okay. And when that prophet says that
you have to follow the Quran for its
legal rulings and he tells you what the
dietary restrictions are that you must
follow and you don't follow them. Are
you actually following the prophet?
>> It's it's so it's it's twofold. It's
similar to like this. For example, you
have Jesus who came and abregated some
of the Torah. And you even bring this
up. You actually quoted this
>> according to the Quran.
>> According to the Quran. Do
>> you believe that?
>> According to the Quran. Don't. That's
not what this is about.
>> You accept that. According to the Quran,
according to the Quran, that's what the
Quran says. That's what you accept it.
Okay. Go ahead.
>> So, according to the Quran, Jesus
abregated some laws of the Torah. Okay.
Now, the Jews did not follow uh not all
of them. Uh there are some of them that
did not follow what Jesus was saying.
However, guess what? way after Jesus
came 600 years later chapter 543 is
telling the Jews why do they come to you
when they have the Torah in which
Allah's judgment is in. So even still
the Quran is telling the Jews to follow
the Torah even though they rejected
Jesus. So they can reject the they even
if they reject the prophets Allah is
still giving them a caveat to follow and
and obey their scriptures.
>> Right. So uh let me let me ask it a
different way. I mentioned perennialism.
So, are you saying that the Quran is
advocating perennialism?
>> I don't know what that is.
>> Okay. I explained it in my opening
statement. You should have took notes.
>> Anyway, the idea that there are multiple
pathways to God and as you said
essentially that the Jews and Christians
can have a right standing with God and
make it to paradise even if they are not
following the prophet Muhammad.
>> Okay. So, it it's twofold. They can only
make it to paradise if they are
believing in all of the revelation of
Allah and all of their messengers,
abiding by their scriptures, if they're
not they're not, you know, uh, legally
bound by the Quran's laws, if they're
not following the Quran's laws, but they
still have to believe it's revelation.
If they reject it as revelation and
reject Muhammad as a prophet, they
cannot make it to paradise.
>> Okay? So when the Quran says that Jesus
is not God and a Christian believes that
Jesus is God, are they rejecting the
prophet's revelation,
>> they're rejecting not only the prophet's
revelation, but they're also rejecting
Allah's revelation in the angel because
the that's that's the dilemma. The Quran
does not know what is in the angel. So
it says that Jesus is not the son of God
while affirming the angel that says he
is the son of God. Thank Welcome to the
dilemma today. Thank you very much. So
you finally arrived at the debate. So
you're admitting that Jews and
Christians, even apart from the Islamic
law, that if they're actually following
the Quran, they must reject your
scriptures. Correct?
>> No. What I'm saying?
>> Oh, so they could believe. Can I finish?
So no, so they could believe. [laughter]
So they could believe. You said no. I'm
going to respond.
>> Let me finish. I didn't get the
I'm the one who's controlling and asking
questions. Let me at least answer.
>> I'm I'm asking questions. So you're
saying that a Christian a Christian a
Christian could believe
>> I let you finish when you when you a
Christian could believe that Jesus is
God and still be and still be following
the Quran. I'm going to go ahead and
finish what I was saying. I'm not your
I'm part of the holy priesth.
>> This is the holy priesthood.
>> I already collected the so as as your
priest this is what I'm going to say. I
said no guys please settle down. Now the
no and when I'm qualifying this by
saying this okay when they believe in
their scriptures that according to the
Quran the Quran does not know what's in
the script let me actually fix this
Allah does not know what's in the
scriptures so he's continuously saying
hey follow your scriptures believe in it
well actually Jesus ain't the son of God
though uh Jesus wasn't crucified not
knowing that's in the scriptures HE'S
SAYING IT'S
WELCOME TO THE DILEMMA.
>> EXACTLY. YOU MADE IT TO THE DEBATE.
>> SO, so when the Quran in 6146
says that Allah prohibited for the Jews
every animal with uncloven hoof, is that
in the Torah?
>> Uh, I believe so.
>> Okay. So, Allah does know that that was
prohibited for the Jews. And he's Let me
finish. You're not asking questions.
You're right. So, I know. Thanks. I got
to cook. So [laughter]
let me finish and tell you that in that
context it's telling the Jews what was
prohibited for them on account of their
transgression. And in the prior verse
contrast it with what is prohibited for
the Muslims. So how could the Jews
follow the Quran when it says that only
pork is prohibited and not what was
prohibited for them before?
>> Oh my gosh. It's like you're not you're
not getting
>> you're not getting it. YOU'RE NOT
GETTING IT.
>> So Jake, let me let me let me go ahead
answer.
>> So the Quran's an authority over it.
>> Can I answer you? It's in authority
over.
>> Can I answer it?
>> Yeah, we're waiting for you. Thank you.
Appreciate it, man. I appreciate it. So,
dude, you're assuming you're assuming
that when the Quran mentions a law that
it's getting it from the scriptures. No.
Muhammad used to hear the traditions of
the Jews when he used to hang out with
them. Matter of fact, you have hadith
that say that the Jews used to recite
the Torah in Hebrew and then explain it
to the Muslims in Arabic. And then
Muhammad goes on to say, "Don't believe
what they say, nor disbelieve what they
say, but say we believe in what was sent
down to us and what was sent down to
you." So according to Muhammad, he
believed in their scriptures. He just
didn't trust everything that they said.
So whenever you're hearing Muhammad or
seeing that the Quran is actually
happens to get something right that's in
our Torah, it's because he heard it and
he happened to get it right this time.
But there's other traditions that he
hears and he adds it into the Quran as
if it's part of the Torah. like when he
quotes the Talmud in other places, he
don't know what the Torah is, man.
>> So when you said earlier that according
to the Quran, the Jews and Christians
are actually supposed to follow the
Quran as a legal authority, does that
mean that the Quran is a legal authority
over the Jews and Christians in their
scriptures?
>> It it means that the Quran can be a
legal authority over the previous
scriptures. However, guess what, Jake?
>> There goes the authority. Watch this.
There goes the authority. Watch this,
Jake. Unfortunately for you, Jake, as
you already admitted, author uh the
Quran or a new revelation superseding
the previous in authority or legal
binding does not mean the previous
revelation is corrupted. It's still
true, but it's not authority. Let me
finish. It doesn't. So, okay. So, if
this means that of parts of your Quran
is not an authority, does that mean it's
not true? No. That's what you said.
>> Listen to the You got to let me land.
You got to let me land. a question.
>> No, I No, I you just asked me a
question. It was rhetorical and I
answered it myself.
>> Okay, so finish.
>> Thank you.
>> You asked me a question.
>> I appreciate it. So just because if we
even grant that the Quran is it
supersedes the scriptures in legal
binding authority, it doesn't supersede
the scriptures in the standard of truth
in that sense of the authority. Which is
why I said when I when we say authority,
let me finish. Adam,
>> when we say that the that the previous
that the Quran affirms the authority of
the previous scriptures, I specifically
said meaning that the previous
scriptures are the standard of truth.
Good
>> and they're legally binding on the Jews
and Christians. Address that.
>> So it's partly it's only partly
authoritative. It's not fully legally
authoritative. The Quran is fully
legally authoritative over the previous
scriptures. Correct.
>> In some senses. Now, however, that's not
an accept. Let me finish. Okay. So, I
guess again you're you're showing how
how silly you are. If if going with uh
uh something that is if going with
something that is legally binding over
something that is no longer legally
binding means picking and choosing that
means you as a Muslim are picking and
choosing when it comes to alcohol. When
the Quran at one point said that alcohol
is good, just don't come drunk to the
other. Authoritative. Allow me to finish
the app. you know, follow your own
argument. So when the Quran in one place
says that, hey, you could drink, just
don't come to the majid drunk. But then
in another verse, it says don't drink at
all because wine is the works of Satan.
I guess you're picking and choosing what
you believe. Huh? Because one verse
became more binding over another.
According to Jake, if that is the case,
then you're picking and choosing. You're
in trouble, not me.
>> All right, time's up, right?
>> That's time right there. That's time.
Thank you guys for fantastic crossex.
All right, at this time we'll take a
fiveminute intermission. Uh, make sure
you get your questions in. We'll come
back with a with a Q a closing and a Q&A
20 30-minute Q&A.
Fire. So, it was great. Um, so we're
going to jump into our closing uh fivem
minute closings for each each opponent
and then we'll follow with a 30-minute
Q&A. So Avery, you're at backup
for your fivem minute closing and uh as
always we'll start your time as soon as
you begin to speak.
>> All right. So first of all, I want to
give honor to the triune God who gives
us victory in all our steps and all our
ways. It's the father, son, and holy
spirit that we are able to do this.
>> Please hold your applause. Please hold
your applause.
>> It's uh the father, son, and holy spirit
that gives us the strength to do this.
Um I also still again want to thank Jake
for uh doing this debate. the Islamic
dilemma is probably one the toughest uh
topics to do and so as a Muslim debater
to have the courage to come and debate
that uh is is you know something to be
applauded. So thank you Jake for taking
the debate. Um guys, and all in all,
what we saw is that Jake wasted his
entire cross-examination
going over a fruitless authority or
legal binding argument that by his own
admission does not demonstrate that the
previous scriptures are corrupted or
untrue. So in his he did not touch or
bring any argument against the Islamic
dilemma. In fact, he affirmed it and
contradicted himself over and over. But
let's relay it again. Let's relay it one
one last time. The Quran affirms the
preservation,
the inspiration and the authority of the
Bible, of the previous scriptures. By
authority, we mean that the the previous
scriptures are the standard of truth.
Without the previous scriptures, the
Quran falls apart. Well, if you if
you're in doubt about what the Quran is
saying, go and ask those who've been
reading the scripture before you.
According to chapter 3:81, how the
people will recognize and know that this
actually is the prophet of the covenant
is if he confirms and is in line with
the scriptures they have. According to
the Quran, our scriptures is the end
all, be all 10 toes, standard foundation
of truth, not the Quran. The Quran is
the one that's supposed to be in line
with it. If it's not, it's false. If it
is, it's false again because we see that
the Quran contradicts the pre uh
previous scriptures. Now, what we see
here with the Islamic dilemma, ladies
and gentlemen, all over the place, verse
after verse after verse, we see that the
Quran is consistency. I I'm reading the
Quran charitably. I'm letting the Quran
speak for itself. Over and over and over
again, we give verses where the Quran
says it's confirming the previous
scriptures. It's confirming what you
have. It's confirming that which you
possess. It's confirming what is with
you. Over and over and over and over and
over again, the Quran says that the
previous scriptures are true. But the
Muslims want to come and tell us, no,
actually the Quran is arguing that
they're not true. not the ones that you
have currently. But when the Quran says
that what we have is confirmed by the
Quran, that it what we have is true,
what we possess is true, it's saying the
opposite of what the what the Dawa guys
are saying. So there they have a uphill
battle. They are arguing against Allah,
not the Christians. It's not me who made
this up. Allah, Muhammad, they they're
the ones who are saying this. They're
the ones who fought the battle for our
Bible. I didn't have to lift a finger.
And I want to thank the Quran for that.
I didn't have to lift a finger. When you
comes to the previous scriptures, the
authority argument, we're not arguing
over whether or not something is legally
binding or not. You could have the Quran
be legally binding over the previous
scriptures in the present time of
Muhammad and still not and still be
within the dilemma because according to
the Quran these scriptures are true.
If there's any point where the Quran is
not in line with these scriptures, then
the Quran is false. whether it's a it's
legally binding on the Jews and
Christians or not. If it agrees with the
pre if it's in line if it's not in line
with the previous scriptures, it's
false. If the previous scriptures are
corrupted, the Quran is false. The
Islamic dilemma and there it is. It's
done for. So with this being said, with
Allah fighting the battle for us, for
the Bible, the Quran explicitly says
that you are not allowed to pick and
choose what parts you believe in. This
doesn't mean that you go with uh legally
binding verses and verses that are not
legally that that's not what it says.
You have to believe all of it is from
Allah. All of it is from God. even the
even the parts that's not legally
binding on you anymore. And if you don't
if you believe in part of the scripture
and reject other parts of the scripture
according to Allah, you're going to
hell. I guess I'm in a good position
because I believe in all of it. I
believe all of it is from God, which is
why Islam is false because it
contradicts the Bible. Thank you guys so
much for coming out for us.
All right, we'll have five minute
closing from Jake.
Okay, I want to thank Marlin and the
Gospel Truth once again for hosting
tonight's debate.
>> [clears throat]
>> I have to thank Avery in some sense uh
for showing up, but I don't think it
really was good for him to be honest. Uh
he should have stayed home if I'm if I'm
actually being fair. Um listen, he keeps
making this big to-do that the Quran and
the Islamic dilemma has nothing to do
with authority. Has nothing to do with
authority. He just actually conceded the
debate in the same wood that his teacher
David Wood did just a few days ago. He
said, "Guys, look, we could still run
the Islamic dilemma if we remove the
authority part and just go based off of
preservation and inspiration. Yes, you
could try to run the argument, but it
would be a different argument. We're
waiting for you to openly and explicitly
concede on the authority point. Unless
and until you do so, we're going to keep
collecting Jiza, my friend." Now getting
to the point about him saying this is
not actually the argument. I want to
play a clip for you guys. I hope you can
hear this.
>> For example, if the if the prophet
sallall alaihi wasallam or someone had a
doubt about whether alcohol was prohibit
prohibited, do they go would they have
to go to the Bible and see okay is
alcohol prohibited and then based off
off of that take whatever the Bible
says. Is that's what is that what you
believe in?
>> Can I respond?
>> Yep.
>> Okay. M matter of fact, let me just
answer you fully. Uh, yes, I do. I do
believe that. Now, let me respond in
full. Daniel.
>> Wow. So, yes, I do believe that. When
you're asked the question about
Listen, you guys need to be quiet. This
is my time to talk. I know it's hard.
>> All right, guys. That's it. Listen,
let's let's settle down. Let's go
closing.
>> I know it's hard on the Musher King.
Trust me, nothing else in it changes
anything. He goes on to give a more
detailed explanation about the fact that
the Torah and Injil are actually legally
binding over the Quran. I know it's hard
on you, brother. No, no, you're not
going to be able to live this down
because you got caught lying right here
red-handed. The fact of the matter is
that they have been using inspiration,
preservation, and authority. Now, he
wants to change the definition of
authority to the standard of truth.
Well, if it's inspired and it's
preserved, then that would mean it's
true. SO, WHAT DOES authority add
anything to that? That was never the
definition. Authority is the fact that
it's still binding and able to be
followed for Jews and Christians. That's
what the authority is. You went even
further than that. And let's listen to
David Wood. What your teacher says here.
If you're representing it as, well, the
the Islamic dilemma is claiming that the
Torah and the Gospel are legal
authorities over Muslims and Muslims
have to obey them and not the Quran.
Okay, you can go you can run with that
and we're all going to say that's not
what any of us has ever said at all. So
try again. Better luck next time.
Interesting. I I wish I'd understood
that because then I could have just
>> So So there you go. David Wood says
that's not what any of us have ever
said. Avery just said that that if a
Muslim asks and has a question about the
legal ruling of alcohol, they must
consult the Torah and Injil and whatever
the legal ruling is, it must agree with
it. The Quran must agree with all the
legal rulings. You've thrown that out
because you no longer can defend that
position. But even you throwing that
out, we still got you to concede the
debate, Avery, because at the last part
of the cross-examination period, he
said, "Yes, Jake." And he even admitted
it in his closing statement that the
Quran is a legal authority in some sense
over the previous scriptures. That means
that according to Avery, your scriptures
are only partly authoritative, not fully
authoritative. And when you open the
door for that, Quran 285, according to
your interpretation, refute you. That is
about legal authority because it's about
the Jews refusing to follow certain
aspects of their text. So, you fall
victim to Quran 1094 and 285, your own
argument. You already admitted that
according to 350 Jesus abregated laws
from the Torah for the Jews. So Aver's
ridiculous and absurd interpretation of
the Quran is Quran tells Jews and
Christians to follow the legally binding
aspects of the Quran but yet at the same
time says oh it's okay if you don't. you
could f Does it make any sense that the
Quran tells you to follow a prophet and
his rulings and then by the way it says
oh no it's okay if you don't that's his
interpretation not mine but I want to
invite everybody here to read the Quran
and to think and ponder about this
debate and see who actually is
representing the Quran correctly Jake or
Avery. Thank you.
All right, let's give another round of
applause for the debaters.
All right, we are entering into our Q&A
portion. 30-minute Q&A. So, the way this
Q&A is going to work is that both
whoever gets the question initially has
one minute to respond. Uh, then the
opponent gets one minute to respond and
the person who got the question
initially gets 30 seconds to respond.
All right. So, this question, let me
make sure I get this timer right.
All right. So, this question is for you,
Avery. How do you reconcile Quran 5:30
where Jesus confirms the Torah but makes
lawful what was previously unlawful for
children of Israel if they are supposed
to follow the Torah?
>> Yeah. So,
>> I think he means 350, not 530.
>> 350. Yeah.
>> Okay.
So uh this is just an example of
abrogation or when something is legally
binding or and o over something that
used to be legally binding but no longer
is. So again even I says that this means
that Jesus is following and adhering to
and affirming the Torah while at the
same time he uh makes something lawful
that used to be unlawful and vice versa.
This doesn't mean that he doesn't
believe in the Torah because it
literally just said that he affirmed it
and confirmed it right in the same
sentence. So, he confirms it while uh
bringing in his law that is the the the
new law or that uh supersedes the old
law. He still believes in all of the
Torah. Just because he abregates
something doesn't mean that he now
thinks that what was previously the law
is now corrupted or untrue all of a
sudden. This is the problem with Jake's
argument.
>> All right, Jake.
>> Yeah, I'm sorry. Can you just restate
the rules for this in terms of the
questioning?
>> Yeah. So, the question was initially for
Avery. So, he gets one minute to
respond. Then after after him, now you
get one minute, but then after that,
Avery gets 30 seconds.
>> Okay. Yeah. Cool. I just didn't want to
go over time. All right. So, uh this is
actually a good question. It's something
I just mentioned in my closing statement
there where in Quran 350 Jesus is
actually saying that he's confirming
what is in his hands right in the hands
and at the same time of doing that he's
actually abregating certain
[clears throat] laws from the Torah.
What does this mean? This means and
please please stop misrepresenting my
argument. I'm not saying that abrogation
equals corruption. I'm arguing that
abrogation equals no longer fully
authoritative. Pay attention. If the law
is no longer legally binding to be
followed, it's no longer fully legally
authoritative. That's the argument.
Actually respond to it.
>> That's not the Islamic dilemma. So
because he's bringing up this fruitless
uh uh point has nothing to do with the
Islamic as he just said it. It this does
not prove the previous scriptures are
true or that you don't believe in them.
Uh so what why what are we doing here?
STOP BRINGING THIS UP.
>> All right. Uh this question is for you
Jake.
>> Yeah.
>> One word of scriptures corrupted and do
any uncorrupted copies exist?
>> Um this is a matter of dispute. uh the
Quran and Sunnah don't explicitly say
when the previous scriptures were
corrupted. But my my personal position
is that uh well the Quran does
explicitly say that uh what was
originally revealed was oral. You have
to understand the Quran's position on
revelation is that it's an oral
revelation that's typically given from
God to the angel Gabriel and then from
the angel Gabriel to the particular
prophet in question. and then at some
point just like the Quran it is later
reduced to writing. Uh my position in
terms of the uh so-called Torah and in
geil the original revelations to Moses
and Jesus respectively is that the of
course the oral revelation was
uncorrupted but in virtue of it being
reduced to writing very early on I don't
know exactly when but very early on it
was corrupted textually. That's my
position.
>> Avery.
>> Yeah. Do you guys see how he said that's
his position? Not Allah's position. Nor
is it Bkari's position and I abbas's
position. Bukari says that they are that
these scriptures were not textually
corrupted but they're only
misinterpreted
uh misrepresented. This is why he
correctly said that there's dispute on
this because their most their their most
authoritative scholars believed that the
scriptures textually were preserved
because the Quran and they give reasons
because one one of the arguments they
give is actually one of the arguments
that he goes against where it says that
none can change the words of Allah. This
is one of the arguments that they use to
prove that the verse that the scriptures
are textually preserved. Also they use
the hadith where Muhammad says when they
came to Muhammad for uh for a judgment
Muhammad says bring the Torah and says I
believe in you and the one who revealed
you. That's in Suna Abu Dawoud.
According to them this was enough to
demonstrate that the scriptures were
textually preserved or else Muhammad
would never have said this. So yeah
>> 30 seconds.
>> Okay. So Avery just brought a whole
bunch of stuff that I don't have enough
time to respond to that he didn't bring
up in the entire debate. Alb Bukari did
believe in textual corruption because he
quoted Ibn Abbas and what I quoted
earlier and all you could say was Ib
Abbas contradicted himself. The text and
hadith from Sunn Abu D. The portion that
you read that I believe in you and the
one who revealed you that is not in all
of the other hadiths that are
transmitting the same report. That's why
many scholars have deemed that part of
the hadith to be weak.
All right, Avery, this question is for
you. Why do you insist on uh the Quran's
absolute confirmation of the scripture
when that is not required for Islamic
dilemma to work?
>> Um I'm just going with what the Quran
says. So the Quran absolutely confirms
the previous scriptures to whoever asked
that. So um yeah the because the Quran
absolutely affirms the truth and the
authority the the previous scriptures as
the standard of truth and the
preservation of the scriptures. When
Muslims come and tell us oh well no uh
it's actually corrupted it you don't
have it anymore or you have part parts
of it or some of it is true they're
going against what the Quran says. So
I'm only reading what Allah says that's
why it works. Notice that in his
response now, and this is this is
something that we're going to the
Muslims here, we're going to have to
make this go uh viral. We have to keep
focusing on this authority point until
they submit because of the fact now
every time he responds, he only wants to
talk about inspiration and preservation.
They're throwing the authority part out,
which is more than 50% of the verses
that they t typically cite. If they're
admitting now that they interpreted all
those wrong, then they could be also
wrong about the other verses. It's very
simple. You have to follow the argument.
It's going to take time, but it's going
to catch on.
>> This is how you know somebody is bad at
debating because they can't listen.
>> Did Did you guys hear me throw out
authority or did I just say it? You did.
>> Did I not just say what authority is?
>> So, I'm including I'm including
preservation. I'm including inspiration.
And I'm including authority. I'm just
teaching you what that means, Jake.
>> All right. Question for you, Jake. Given
the Islamic view of God's providence,
why would God decree for the Torah in
the angel to be corrupted?
>> Uh, I don't know what they mean by
Quran's view of God's providence, but we
believe that God decrees everything. if
that's what he's referring to. The
questioner, uh, why would God decree for
um certain scriptures to be corrupted?
You could ask that about anything that
you think appears to be negative. Why
would God decree for so certain prophets
to be killed as the Quran and the uh Old
Testament affirm, right? Uh uh we
believe as Muslims, as many Christians
also believe the same thing. We believe
that God's divine creed that he has a
hecka or wisdom for everything that he
does in the case of letting previous
scriptures uh go away. The reason is
because that they were only for specific
groups of people at a specific time.
Whereas the Quran and the prophet
Muhammad are for all people and all
times going forward.
>> Yeah, this demonstrates the incoherence
of the Quran. Ladies and gentlemen, why
in the world would Allah decree? Now, we
didn't get an answer to this, but why in
the world would Allah decree, will plan
for his own scriptures, his own
revelation to be corrupted and distorted
only to tell us later on, hey guys,
follow your scriptures, uh, abide by
your scriptures, judge by your
scriptures. Oh, don't forget they are
corrupted though. I willed it, by the
way. It makes no sense. It is
incoherent, which is why the Islamic
dilemma is so powerful that they're
stuck here.
No, not at all. When you say that why
did God actually decree for something to
happen? I can ask you the same question
about anything. I already answered the
question. He decreed for this to happen
because those scriptures were only for
certain groups of people and it was time
bound. Whereas the Quran is the final
revelation. It's not time bound. It's
for all people going forward.
>> All right. There's a question for Ay. Uh
as a Christian, I as a Christian reject
and do not accept the Quran as a
revelation from God. Why do you say I
should I should follow the Quran? It is
not God's word and I reject it. Did I
mishar you?
>> Yes, you mis you misunderstood what I
was saying. I was I'm talking about the
Quran's perspective. Ladies and
gentlemen, let me make it clear. I do
not believe in the Quran. I believe in
the original Quran before it got
corrupted. Um um and so there's some
truth in the Quran today from the
original. Whatever aligns with the
Bible, that's the parts that's true.
Whatever disagrees with the Bible,
that's the part that's corrupted. And so
um it was corrupted by um man. So I
believe in been the original Quran
before it was tampered with. Does that
sound stupid? That's what he's arguing.
>> That's not what I'm arguing at all. What
I'm actually arguing what you haven't
been able to deal with the argument. And
I know I know it's hard on the musher.
they can't handle it. But the reality is
you haven't been able to deal with the
argument when you claim that the Torah
and Injil are still ongoing legal
authorities and then you admit no in
actual fact the Quran is a legal
authority over the Jews and Christians
and previous scriptures because you guys
have to be our and pay the Jiza. You've
admitted that we've collected Jiza and
therefore we have demonstrated that your
argument regarding the authority of
previous scriptures is false.
>> Again, legal binding is irrelevant
because according to your scriptures in
your own statement 929, us being demies
and having to pay the jiza according to
Islamic law does not have anything to do
with the corruption or the falsehood of
the previous scriptures. So therefore,
the scriptures are still the standard of
truth even though we have to pay the
jizzy according to the Quran. Well, I
mean, I'm waiting for you to arrive to
the debate, man.
>> All right, Jake, this question for you.
Um, if 548 is about Jesus and Christians
not following the Quran, but gives a
caveat to follow the scriptures instead.
Um,
some of y'all penmanship is rough.
>> [laughter]
>> I don't even understand the question to
be honest. Can you read it again from
the top?
>> All right. F548 is about Jews and
Christians not following the Quran, but
gives a caveat to follow the scripture
instead. Wouldn't that still be
following the Quran and not a
contradiction?
>> I I really don't understand the
question, you know. Uh but I'll answer
about 548 where it says that the Quran
is a muan over uh the previous
scripture. And if you read the very next
verse 49, it says the prophet peace be
upon him is to judge between the people
of the book by the revelation that he
received. Which means again that the
Quran is a legal authority over previous
scripture which Avery has admitted. So
he's thrown the authority part out. He
said no, Islamic dilemma is only about
whether it's true and preserved. It's
not about whether it's to be followed
today. He's thrown out the aspect of
your scriptures needing to be followed
today.
>> Where is Jake? Is he here with us?
>> I'm right here, baby.
>> You sure?
>> Yeah.
>> You good?
>> I'm good.
>> Okay. Uh I I I clearly said that the
Quran affirms the preservation,
inspiration, and authority of the
previous scriptures. What does that mean
by authority? It means that the the
previous scriptures are the standard of
truth. If the Quran is not in line with
them, then the Quran is false. Whether
it is a legal bind is legally binding on
the Jews and Christians or not, the
Quran has to line up with the previous
scriptures or else the Quran is false.
When are you going to touch that?
>> Yeah. Good. So when Mark's gospel says
that all food is lawful, including pork,
and the Quran explicitly says that pork
is haram, it is prohibited. That means
if you are supposed to follow the Quran,
that it is a legal authority over your
previous scripture. You have not been
able to deal with that other than just
asserting. You're still affirming
authority, but it means truth. Well, you
already said it's preserved. And that is
the aspect of regarding truth. So you're
just redundant. You know that you're
busted.
>> Uhhuh.
[laughter]
>> All right, Amy, this question is for
you. [clears throat] Can you address why
you use rhetoric to avoid answering
essential questions Jake asked you in
CrossX?
>> Go ahead.
>> Can you give me a real question? Matter
of fact, how about this? Whoever asked
that question, give give the mic to that
person.
Oh, okay. There they go. Oh, no. Not not
you. It's security. Get the big head one
out of here. But you you can step up.
The one in the white.
>> All right, guys. All right. All right.
All right. All right. All right.
[laughter]
All right.
>> No, no, no. It it was a it was a joke.
>> Oh, because you know I'm Abunori, right?
>> Oh, you're Abunori. Oh, yeah. We can
talk after this then.
>> I would I wouldn't know. I know you. But
uh do you have a a real question because
that's That's stupid.
>> I wish I could say the same thing when I
get stupid questions. All right. But
like but like like for real like does
that or why did you use rhetoric to
avoid the is that like a serious would
you would you
>> I think I think what he's trying to get
at is that you're instead of answering
the question directly because we use
rhetoric regular that's what we use to
communicate but
>> I think what he's getting at is
the type of phraseologies I guess to
avoid the actual question
>> that he's asking so it's not that you're
using rhetoric fundamentally I think
he's just asking you're evading the
question. You're looping around the
question.
>> Okay. I I I just I would like evidence
that I avoided anything because I've
answered everything directly. So that's
he's assuming that I didn't that I
avoided a question. So or an argument.
It's silly. Whoever asked that that was
a stupid question.
>> I mean, I don't have much to add. I
can't really speak on his behalf, but I
think it's been clear on who's answering
questions, who's not, who's
contradicting themselves. I'll let
people be the judge. Oh yeah, they
judging.
>> Yeah, I know. They judging by the Quran.
>> Yeah, that's your false.
>> Yeah,
>> the Quran is on our side. Don't you get
it?
>> That it's illegal authority over you.
What you mean?
>> Does he not get it?
>> It's illegal authority, guys. All right,
guys. Let's move on. Let's move on.
>> Thanks, Demi.
>> All right, so Jake, this question is for
you. Uh, Jews and Christians had the
Torah centuries before Muhammad and
where it were not working together. So,
when exactly was it corrupted? Who did
it? And how did both sides end up with
the same altered text?
>> I mean at this point I'd be that
question was already asked to be fair.
So I could repeat the same answer which
is that the Torah and NGO were
originally oral revelations in virtue of
them being to reduced to writing very
early on they were textually corrupted.
We don't have anything from G for
example the Torah. I mean where is the
the chain of custody going back to
Moses? Where's the chain of custody of
the uh New Testament going back to uh
Jesus? It doesn't exist at all.
>> Avery,
>> what what was the question?
>> Oh, it says uh Jews [clears throat] and
Christians had the Torah uh the Torah
centuries before Muhammad and were not
working together. Uh so when exactly was
it corrupted? Who did it? And how did
both sides end up with the same altered
text?
>> And and just to clarify, Jake, did you
can you repeat the last thing you said?
>> Uh the last thing I said, man,
>> about them not having the gospel or
something like that.
>> I didn't I didn't say the
>> change.
>> I said I said about it going back to
Jesus, the uh New Testament
>> that it does not go back to Jesus.
>> No.
>> Okay. Um Yeah. So guys, this would lead
us to our favorite question, doesn't it?
What's the angil?
>> Because if what we have does not go back
to Jesus, then I guess that would mean
it's not the angil, which would mean he
knows what the angil is and would be
able to tell us what the angil is. Um,
>> but he can't because the Quran doesn't
tell him what the angel is exactly
unless he relies on what we have.
>> And so, um, it looks like according to
the Quran, what we have does go back to
Jesus because the Quran says that and a
matter of fact, he quoted it chapter 7
vers7.
uh that those who believe in the
unlettered prophet who can neither read
nor write is written in the Torah and
gospel with them in the seventh century.
Well, we have the New Testament in the
seventh century. Um that's what even
your commentators quote uh that that we
have when they're quoting John and and
all this kind of stuff about Muhammad
being in the scripture. So according to
a lot of commentary, we have what goes
back to Jesus. That's that's tough. But
you can tell us what the angel is if we
don't have.
>> Yeah, I can very easily. So the Quran
tells you what the NGL is. It was a
revelation that was given to Jesus peace
be upon him in his own language. 57:27
Quran 144. Very clear. Answered your
silly question. Secondly, when it comes
to the New Testament, you don't have
that as being revelation to Jesus. The
only things we consider are what are
said to be attributed to Jesus. You can
say the red letter text, some of which
is authentic and some which is not.
I still don't know what it is, you know.
>> All right. So, this question is for a
>> Got to keep up, brother.
>> Question for Avery. What specifically in
the Torah in the and and especially the
gospel contradict the Quran?
>> Yeah. So, a a lot of things. So, in the
in the Quran, one of the most heinous
things that you can say about Allah is
that he has a son. You'll find this in
chapter 19 uh verses 88 to 93. And Allah
is very clear that the only relationship
that you can have with him is a slave to
master relationship. You cannot come to
him as a figurative son, metaphorical
son, literal son. Not at all. While the
scriptures teach that not only um uh is
Jesus the actual begotten son of the
father, but that believers are the
adopted sons of God. That Israel is are
the adopted sons of God as the nation
that he created. While in chapter 5 18,
the Quran says that the Jews are and the
Christians, they say we are the sons of
Allah, his loved ones. He says, then why
does he punish you for your sins? No,
you are but men and he punishes who he
wills and he uh guides who he wills.
Right? While in the in the Torah in
Deuteronomy 8, the Bible says that as a
father disciplines his son, so I
discipline you. So according to the
Quran, a father wouldn't discipline his
son, but according to the Bible, that's
exactly what a father does if he loves
his son. So the Quran contradicts a very
core issue about God's character and
nature as being father and having a son.
Uh, while it's opposite in Islam,
>> yeah, I already had to correct David
Wood on this the other day. The Quran
does not completely negate sunship, it
negates the typical meanings of sunship
that Christians apply to Jesus, like him
being eternally begotten of the father,
which the Nyine Creed says, which
doesn't make any sense at all, or being
a literal son of uh God. It does not
outright negate the fact that there
could be uh God and scholars even talk
about this in previous Sharia or
previous laws. Uh just as prostration at
a particular time was not in and of
itself considered to be uh disbelief if
you prostrated to somebody but in light
of the behavior going on God then says
no this can no longer be the case. It's
the same thing with the terms father and
son which the Christians have unfort
unfortunately innovated and used in an
improper way.
>> Um so just to give a little bit more on
this uh the Quran also contradicts like
the character of God like you have a law
where God says that if you divorce a
woman and she marries another she's not
allowed to come back to you. That is an
abomination to the Lord. Um but in the
Quran, she cannot come back uh to you
unless she slept with uh that that that
husband and then she can come back to
you. So what the the Quran allows for
what uh God says is an abomination,
meaning a a moral depravity. So you have
a bunch of examples like this in the
Quran and the scriptures.
>> All right, Jake, this question for you.
How do you find Muhammad in the Bible?
How can you trust the Bible to find
Muhammad if it's corrupted? Okay. So,
uh, regard this is not what the debate
is about. The debate is not about where,
uh, the prophet Muhammad is in the
previous scripture. But if you want to
see a good example of that, you can go
rewatch actually I'm plugging Marlin in
Gospel Truth here. They just had a
debate on that topic between a Muslim
and a Christian. And I think the Muslim
did a fairly good job. You can go to
passages like Daniel uh, chapter 2. uh
you can go to passages in the New
Testament like in uh Matthew when it
talks about uh the parable that was
mentioned. All of these points uh point
to we believe the prophet Muhammad and
are clearer examples of the prophet
Muhammad being prophesized in the Torah
and in Gil rather than uh Jesus being
prophesized in the Old Testament.
>> He said that this is not what the debate
is about. Y'all is he okay? Yeah, I'm
I'm great, bro.
>> If the if the scriptures are corrupted,
how can you trust them to find Muhammad
in there? That's the Islamic dilemma.
And he said that this is not what the
debate is about, man. You're lost, bro.
So, according to you, I according to
this argument here, the scriptures are
corrupted. How can you find Muhammad in
corrupted scriptures? Now, you're going
to these scriptures that you believe are
tampered with and corrupted. How can we
trust that these are actually accurate?
You can't. You're just fishing and the
the Quran sends you on a wild goose
chase. doesn't tell you where to find
Muhammad, doesn't quote any scriptures
that say, "Yeah, this is where Muhammad
is in, and just sends you, you got to
pick and choose. Okay, you know what?
This seems to align with me, so I'm
gonna go ahead and uh and and and and
and choose to believe in this and say
this about Muhammad." Unfortunately, the
per the places they go forces them to
commit. Sherk, he just mentioned Daniel
2, the son of man who receives glory and
power and everybody's going to be
worshiping him. That's Muhammad. Okay.
So he said that we don't have any
examples of where this is being
specified. In actual fact, if you
understood and knew Islamic literature,
you would know that in the a hadith
there are specific examples like uh
Isaiah chapter 42 is uh paraphrased and
it's many scholars have said that it's
referring to Isaiah 42 and the coming of
the prophet Muhammad. So there are
examples of this in our scriptures and
there are examples where the early
scholars who actually knew the prophet
Muhammad directly explicitly tell us
some examples of where he's prophesized
in the in their books.
>> Like where
>> I just told you pay attention.
>> Also they called Daniel.
>> No, I said Isaiah 42. Pay attention.
>> Where you getting Daniel from?
>> Pay attention.
>> All right, guys. Uh Jake, all the rest
of the questions are for you. Um, so if
you want to answer a couple more
questions, give you a little more time.
>> Yeah, let's do it.
>> To respond to the questions and so we go
for it. Uh, today if previous
revelation, it's like the same question
over and
>> over. So let me let me move on.
>> Um,
>> got a good one.
>> All right. So if the Exodus scroll
establish a deliverance pattern, waters,
wilderness, bread, covenant, how does
Islam explain Jesus fulfilling that same
pattern if the biblical text is
corrupted?
>> Uh I'm not sure what the person is
referring to with that pattern there to
be very honest. Know what I don't know
what he's talking about.
>> I can respond.
>> Go ahead if you could tell me what he's
referring to.
>> Well, okay. So what he's referring to is
that there's within within Jesus's
ministry, he is reflecting the Old
Testament and the path the the pathway
of Israel and where Israel failed, Jesus
actually does the same thing and
succeeds. So like for example, uh Israel
was only supposed to be in the
wilderness for 40 days. Um however,
because of their disobedience or
rebellion, they lasted they were in
there for 40 years. So Jesus, he went to
the wilderness and for to be tempted and
tested and he was there for only 40 days
just like Israel was supposed to be. So
it's stuff like this bread, all this
kind of stuff. These are types uh of of
uh these are typologies where Christ is
fulfilling them which ironically ladies
and gentlemen the corrupted scriptures
are all in line with each other except
until it comes to the Quran.
>> Okay. So basically you're saying that
the New Testament is continuous with the
Old Testament and that it's fulfilling
certain proph Jesus anyway is fulfilling
certain uh prophecies or typologies um
in the Old Testament text. That's what I
understand the question to be saying. Um
yeah so in in that case um as I said go
and watch the recent debate between
inspiring philosophy and um orthodox
Muslim where he admitted that the gospel
of Matthew is clearly circular that is
basically assuming its position it's
using certain typologies to read back
into the Old Testament and if you're
playing by that standard then he
admitted that Muslims can do the same
thing. So, I don't think it's really
that impressive. I don't think that the
claims of typology are really impressive
from the New Testament going back to the
Old Testament.
>> All right, we have about two minutes, so
I think this last question should finish
off the Q&A here.
>> Yeah. Okay,
Jake, you stated that the inverse is not
necessarily true regarding the Quran,
but uh ne Let me start over. Jake, you
stated that the inverse is not
necessarily true regarding the Quran
being false if tested against the Torah.
Can you elaborate on that?
>> Uh, I think he's referring to Quran
1094.
Um, where it says to ask the people of
the book, right? Um, and again, as I
said, it's very clear in the context
that it's referring, it's not
all-encompassing, as Avery is basically
admitting now, because now, as opposed
to what I played from the clip in his
debate with Daniel, he's saying it's not
all-encompassing that we need to look at
everything, including the uh legal
rulings of the Torah and Injil, and that
the Quran must match up with them. He's
even admitting that now it's only partly
an authority over the Quran. according
to him. Well, I agree that it's also
partly authoritative just in a different
context. If you read the context, it's
referring to the stories of the prophet.
This is how it's read and that the the
Jews and Christians who became Muslims
can speak about that because they had
access to those traditions and texts.
>> Avery,
>> uh yeah. So, I mean just again another
re uh misrepresentation of what I said
in 1094. The Quran points to the
previous scriptures as the standard of
truth, which is what an authority is. If
you are the standard of truth, you are
the authority. So when it comes to the
truthfulness of the Quran, whether it
actually is from Allah or not, it is
fully reliant on the previous
scriptures. If it's not in line with
them and what Muhammad then if it's not
in line with them, then what mua then
Muhammad will know that what he's
receiving is false and from Satan, not
from God. So
>> right. So if that includes legal rulings
then your interpretation is busted.
>> Never said it includes.
>> Okay. So it's not all incumbent. So that
means then that it's the standard of
truth for some things but not for legal
rulings. It's only partly a standard of
truth. It's not fully a standard of
truth because of the fact that the Quran
explicitly abregates certain rulings and
disagrees with the legal rulings in the
text. Thanks for conceding the Islamic
dilemma. You have admitted and thanks I
love collecting Jiza.
>> All right, there's uh one more one more
question here. Um and I think this this
ended. What can we all do from tonight
on uh from tonight on to help us all
Jews, Christians, and Muslims to get
along better? To get better, get along
better. Want to start Avery?
[laughter]
>> Sure. Yeah. Um the first thing that that
can happen is that we all come to the
believing uh faith and grace in Jesus
Christ. And then uh I believe that we
can all truly work together. We can all
live together. Um And so, uh, but
despite that, because that's more
idealistic, I think that if we, um, are
able to remove the emotionalism with
behind our disagreements and be able to
have these discussions cordally. It's
not about, oh, I baked you and I I
destroyed you and you're a liar this and
you're a liar that, but you know, uh,
you know, giving each other grace and
being honest with each other, help um um
um what's healthfully disagreeing with
one another. I think that we'll be able
to get along uh in a perfect world. But
we're here, guys.
Uh, I think that's rather rich coming
from a guy who was literally making a
spoon cooking motion during the entire
debate and half the audience is
laughing. I had to do this.
>> I mean, it it seems it seems
>> quite hypocritical coming from you and
also from the same guy who hangs out
with people who desecrate scripture on
on the stream and do a whole bunch of
foul stuff. Not to say that Muslims
aren't doing the same thing. I actually
condemn them when they do. Uh but the
problem is that on both sides uh there
are Muslims and Christians uh doing a
lot of mischievous things to each other
and uh much of these debates has become
about rhetoric and so so-called cooking
and uh yeah I'm I'm responding to that
in kind. I wish it could be a more
polite and uh respectful honest
dialogue, but for whatever reason, it
seems that that isn't the case. So, I
really don't really have a good answer
for that because I think we need uh
people on both sides to truly uh be
working towards that and I don't see
that being done. So, I don't I don't
really have a good solution to be
honest.
>> All right, we'll close that out. Um,
thank you guys for the debate. Round of
applause.
All right. Good stuff. Good stuff. How'
y'all like today?
>> Was it good?
Yeah, definitely. Uh, this is definitely
one for for the record books here.
There's a gray one.